on book TV and now on book TV we are
live with Jon Ronson author of so you've
been publicly shamed the psychopathy
test the men who stare at goats and more
he'll answer your questions for the next
three hours on in depth
Jon Ronson who are them Oh them are two
different types of people they're the
secret rulers of the world who kind of
existed kind of don't exist depending on
what baggage you bring to their
situation
then is a book in which I hung out with
conspiracy theorists and try to sneak in
to the secret room where they believe
the shadowy cabal was trying to secretly
rule the world so them are the
extremists and conspiracy theorists male
also the objects of their possibly
paranoid delusions possibly correct
interpretation of how the world works
did you find the secret room yes I did I
found two secret room I I went I went to
the Bilderberg meeting at the Ceasar
Park Hotel a golfing resort in Sintra
Portugal and I went there with a
conspiracy theorist from this town
called Big Jim Tucker who's now departed
and we tried to infiltrate the
Bilderberg meeting and obviously lots of
conspiracy theorists from all different
stripes believed at Bilderberg are the
you know are the Illuminati so we
scattered around the hotel and then left
and then got chased by men and dark
glasses I I wasn't I should tell you I
wasn't so that the Bilderberg Group even
existed I just went there because I
thought you know this is what conspiracy
theorists believes it was never within
the bus at the time in the mainstream
media I thought this was just a fantasy
so I went there I thought maybe
something's happening but you know I'm
sure it's not important
so we scouted around the hotel meaning
Big Jim Tucker Jones's Forge contacts
with waitresses and chambermaids which
was really unsuccessful and then we left
and then I noticed that a dark green
Lamphere was following us and a chase
ensued and now when I say chase I was
going 30 miles an hour so so was he but
if I had gone faster he would have gone
balusters so we're driving some Sidra to
portugal I am I'm panicking obviously
I've never been chased by the shadowy
henchmen of the secret rulers of the
world if I had nothing nothing to
compare this to you know I've been I've
been um yelled at by neo-nazis on a
number of occasions so I kind of know
what's going on there never been chased
by men adult glasses belong to a shadowy
organization that I didn't even know
existed before this was new so I stopped
the car and he stopped his car and then
I went you know and I went up to his
window it was it was a man in dark
glasses and I'd knocks on the window to
try and explain myself and he wouldn't
look at me just look straight ahead so
then I got back in the car and carried
on driving and then he covered
everything so the first thing I did was
phone up my wife I wish and I said this
is really bad and being chased by the
Bilderberg Group but I'm really upset
and I don't know what to do and I'm
really out of my depth and I'm not even
sure what I'll ever see you again and my
wife said oh you're loving it and then I
phoned up the British Embassy and I said
I'm being followed by a dark green
Lancia belonging to the Bilderberg Group
and the woman for the British embassy
worm yeah I mean who won't go on and I
said I'm sorry but I just heard you take
a sharp breath and she said boy what are
you doing here and I said I said I'm
essentially a humorous journalist out of
my depth do you think you might own the
Bilderberg Group in it and explained
that there but also explained I'm here
and I cut it lowered my voice I said I'm
here with a conspiracy theories called
Big Jim Tucker and with an eyes on The
provocateur and that might be the
problem and mainly maybe you can explain
to Bilderberg that i'm like in the car
with jim tucker
so then she said and this is of
everything that happened that day this
is the thing that stays under the most
she said well the good news is if you
know you're being followed they're
probably just trying to intimidate you
and the dangerous ones would be those
who don't know are following you
so I thought that scam concerts because
what if these people are the dangerous
ones and I just happen to be naturally
good at starting them so then we got
back to our hotel and I had this isn't
too long oh this is okay so then we got
an assist three hours this is like the
patient courses don't may have lost of
interviews so we got back to the hotel
and the woman from the British Embassy
telephoned me and said I've spoken to
the Bilderberg office at the Caesar Park
Hotel and they said that nobody's
following you and how can they call off
the man who doesn't exist
so I said he's behind the tree and he
was there was a man behind the tree and
our two star hotel in Estoril staring at
us
so for the next month I would say I
don't know exactly when it stopped with
the chasing starts because I imagined
myself being chased I had four weeks I
would but at some point it's done and I
wasn't being surveilled anymore so the
bilderbergs do exist where did they get
that name from the first hotel where
they met in 1954 eventually I met like a
rope so like everybody I could it's a
clerical interview like you know
Bilderbergers and nobody wrote back I
have to say by the way that the next day
we went back to the hotel and stayed and
watched these limousines going up the
drive David Rockefeller Henry Kissinger
Vernon Jordan various CEOs Heinz and so
you know stuff was going on so
eventually I managed to speak to two
really important
Bilderbergers one was lord Healey Denis
Healey who was one of the founding
members or original members and he
explained what Bilderberg meant to him
is that this is just a second world war
and they'd all lived through Hitler and
they believed that giving power to
business who believed in don't have no
ideology they just believed in money was
a safe thing to do than to have power in
the hands of these overly ideological
politicians so so the idea was globalism
it I thought will will be globalist we
will we will invite up-and-coming
politicians with heads of business and
we will like you know have private
conversations and try and try and
promote the idea of globalism to
up-and-coming politicians Jon Ronson did
you enjoy your time with Jim Tucker yeah
I mean at the time it was terrifying
of course but now I'm older and this is
true of a lot of my adventures I also
snuck into Bohemian Grove the weird cut
a right-wing version of Bilderberg where
you know where they have like rituals
and well you know papier-mache effigies
are thrown into fiery bellies of giant
stone owls I've spoken to one of their
meetings to more successfully actually
and I think in all of these exemptions
at the time you want to do nothing less
than this stuff you know I'm not a
adrenalin type person you know but
looking back these are these are they
these are the great day you know this
misadventures though I think other great
days who is Omar Bakri and how did you
become his chauffeur I'm a battery
mohammad was an Islamic militant living
in London announced in about 1995 but he
wouldn't rest until he saw the flag of
Islam flying over Downing Street
and I realized that he just flipped a
couple of miles away from me in North
London and I thought it would be funny
back in these days it all just you know
it's like if you ask me why was I doing
this story this is when I was in that
mind mid-20s late twenties you know why
did I want to do the story my aunts
would always be the same it might be
funny I was just looking things have
changed but that
then I was looking for it might be funny
so I thought it might be funny just
making to build a boost meeting and it
might be funny to hang out within the
battery for a year while he tries to
overthrow democracy and establish an
Islamic state and he was calling himself
bin Laden's man in Great Britain and so
on and so we called him up
named offense all did who's now really
successful movie director and so can we
spend a year with you while you
overthrow you know tentacle democracy
and he said ok and so he went with her
and on the first day the first thing we
did was watch The Lion King because
that's the only way he can relax
he said they call me the lion they call
me the great a great warrior the great
fighter and then he needed to get a
collection box for Hamas so he went to
the local wholesale warehouse and the
only collection boxes they had in stock
with these giant novelty plastic
coca-cola bottles so I said isn't it
funny that you're you know collecting
money to overthrow the West and these
palpable symbols of Western corruption
that it was like yeah that didn't want
anyone to engage and become the guy
Oriole and then we spent a few months
with him on enough you know shuffling
into to the cash-and-carry and
chauffeuring him to office world where
he got his islam the future of Britain
pamphlets photocopied because of office
world's special price promised that if
you if you find a photocopying services
Cheeta office world will give you double
the double the difference or something I
remember one time I was with Omar at the
counter of this world and he was getting
some leaflets that said crushed the
pilot State of Israel and a couple of
feet up there was a Hasidic Jew
getting sheet music photocopies for the
Bar Mitzvah and oh my was like you know
take you for the sideways glances at the
Hasidic to the acidity was I think it's
like Wade glasses at Omar and then Omar
turned to me and said very sensitive
moment and then he said you though I've
let you in my life
I would like something in return and I
said what and he said you know can you
can you drive me to this beating it up
in Birmingham so I I drove him to what
was basically is one guy starts to say
like a secret terrorist leasing but it
was definitely a secret radical Islam
meeting at this country house in
Birmingham and Omo they wouldn't let us
in and oh my got into trouble for like
bringing us along so we had to wait in
the parking lot while Omar came and
bought this truck I said is that I can
bring you tacos
we said yes please and so we're in the
curve loudly big joke Isis where Omar
was doing god knows loss of this in this
sort of and real spooky Hogwarts he
house in in burning and and and then
elma outed me as a Jew it's his he had
training camp in Crawley which is near
Gatwick Airport and he said had been
with Omar for a year never discussed my
religion and but he said he suddenly
said you know look at me with the
infidel jarosite oldest he had trainees
he to look at me with the infidel John
who is a Jew and the old words are and
and I said surely it's better to be a
Jew than an atheist and someone in the
crowd went oh isn't I mean dad and I
said that because actually I am an
atheist and well I having said that she
tripping sadder she had traded Kent and
then they all surrounded me and said ask
me what it was like to be a do and one
of them had been never message ooh and
they were like treating me like a kind
of rare fish you'd find at the bottom of
the coral reef and then this is all like
1996-1997 and I remember at the time I
met somebody from the Board of Deputies
the British news is like the Jewish
cupboard to his version of the
anti-defamation league I mean the
British version of the idea and he said
you know Britain I think he meant me as
well as Britain hasn't woken up to what
Islamic
terrorism actually means and I remember
thinking it ah paranoid and then you
know four years later and ever since
2001 Ouma's people have been implicated
in acts of terrorism when I tell most
people there's been a number of
occasions where a suicide bomber has
blown themselves up and would have Oma's
number you know stored in his mobile
phone this happened on a on a number of
occasions somebody one of the drivers
who would crawl a whether he had
training camp was ended up blowing
himself up somewhere and Omer himself
now is in prison and in bay roads and so
a few people have said well were you in
with naive that this was happening and
you were making the kind of comic story
this was like a burgeoning thing and
you're in the middle of it but you
presented this as a kind of comic story
and I guess I guess my answer is you
know everything that happened happened
all the comedy and the third he happened
and and we were there and we we were
there by luck in a way but we were there
filming it and and so I think it's a
kind of valuable record of the world
being about to change
with nobody knowing that it was about
change was your time with Randy Weaver
and his family for the same reason no of
all the stories in my book them that
that was that was the one story that you
know I took a completely different
attitude oh it was it was a you know a
terrible human judge did it what I what
I love about that story it's the first
time I ever really told a story where
the people who most people would
represent as a villains come over as
humanistic and explored Randy knew
written and human thank you what he saw
as certainly flawed and
I'm sure feels partly responsible for
what happened to assembly I'm sure he
does but nonetheless it was a really
interesting story for me as a journalist
where you know the Weaver family were
the the colonel you know with a kind of
heart of the story in in every way in
every way padded tails and I never done
that before I'd never have never
witnessed all they were were the people
who most people would think of as the
villains
well actually the people who I was you
know feeling great sympathy and empathy
for because I explained what the story
is going to think a lot of people have
kind of forgotten it now family of white
separatist conspiracy theorists believe
in him Bilderberg and believe in all of
this stuff new world order go to live on
top of a mountain in Idaho because I
kind of think if we come live free on
top of the mountain in Idaho you know
where canula free and their big error
was that they would go to the nearby
Aryan Nations the white supremacy place
and Randi insists that you know he was
never a white supremacist you know but
there was a kind of overlap in the Venn
diagram of what the weavers believed and
what the white supremacist believes that
you know he never considered himself you
know at Heartland and anyway so he would
go there for like their picnics and so
on and the kids were young you know nine
ten years old
including a girl I got to know really
well and got to like hugely Rachel
Weaver one of the daughters and anyway
like a lot of white supremacy hangouts
this one was infiltrated by the federal
government by the way can I take a
slight detour for second because when I
was writing the Randy Weaver story a
when two Aryan Nation foolishly thinking
if I said I'm a sender Andy Weaver's
everything would be fine so I drove that
pass all the signs have said like no
Jews and Jews have allowed Jews to in
fact now I got a churro you know
and immediately got surrounded by these
you know skinheads terrifying men young
men the alienation said was about to be
closed down so they kind of had nothing
to lose
and these men surrounded me and started
yelling yelling at me what is your
blotch of genealogy and I said my
genealogy and I said I'm Church of
England and one of these guys made a
joke to kind of alleviate the situation
that old Church of England every ones
who make you give all your money or
something made some joke and everything
can relax and I've often wondered
whether that that one might be there
undercover agent protecting my ass at
that moment joy do it Randy would go to
this place with his wife Vicki and his
kids and it goes like the summer camps
and so on and an undercover agent saw
Randy there and presumably thought
here's somebody we can work with a
slightly crazy person who's friends with
much crazier people so they are
surrounding if he would be an informant
and he said no he said no in quite a
grand stand a way like a big no so then
they sent somebody to entrap him they
got him they said we sell us a gun and
Randy said yes and we said well he saw
lost the gun there so hungy soared away
and it was below the legal limit so they
said look you've sold us an illegal
weapon when you will go to prison unless
you come work for us
and Randy said no and Randy dug his
heels in put his family in the cabin
stayed there a long time of it like a
year and a half
federal agent he's that you can't you
know you'll never take me off this land
you know stupid excuse me super business
and the agents were like watching and
Italy one day one of the agents the ATS
got too close to the cabin and the dogs
started barking and the dog started
chasing the agents and Randy's little
boys Sammy's 12 years old look much
younger look like nine chased with a
friend of the family who was there
chased the Regents down the hill
the agents hidden the bush came out said
you've shot my and shot the dog and
killed the dog and then Sammy said you
shot my dog you son of a [ __ ] and she
fired um didn't hit anybody but fired
and then the agents opened up and shot
Sammy's arm almost off and Sammy yelled
as I'm coming home dad and ran up the
hill and the agents shot him in the back
and killed him one of the agents got
shots and killed at the same time after
and you know maybe maybe it was the
family friend maybe it was friendly fire
you know think we don't know
I presume people don't know then the
next headed drug Sammy's body into the
cabin on the shed then the next day
Randy came out and a shot Randy the FBI
and then they shot Vicky Weaver in the
head as she was holding her baby in the
doorway and then the feed into for about
twelve days until finally the family
came out and the family the girls were
awarded a million dollars each in
compensation and that was that's about
that was a story
um I guess the whole thing about them
really is it's a book about a kind of
pressure cooker of of craziness leaks
you know the conspiracy theorists were
getting crazier and so were our
responses towards them things are just
going up and up and up and up and then
you know the book came out just before
9/11 in reindeer we were still alive
what you doing the last I heard around
he he was selling his book at gun shows
and have your photograph taken with
Randy Weaver four for five dollars or
something Randy I hope you won't mind me
saying this
in public Randy's very grandstanding
even he said something terrible to me at
one point about the the agents had been
killed
yeah when Sammy was killed he said you
know he's not worth more than my dog he
said to me but in private I really got
the sense that Randy shoulders you know
a terrible burden knows that he was part
of this escalation of hostilities and
that Sammy and Vicky would still be
alive if you know if he hadn't acted
wavin he dudes
Jon Ronson and we'll talk about some of
the other people you write about but
your other books but how do you get to
know these people how do you how do they
why do they say yes to you um will
increasingly it past your passion and
and empathy I've been writing books now
for nearly well 15 milli 20 years and
the older I get the more I see you know
my fellow human beings including the
ones demonized by society for whatever
reason as fully rounded empathetic
complicated human beings a mix of
talents and sins a mix of wisdom and
stupidity I mean though there are
exceptions of course there are people
whose whose faults and transgressions
are so serious it overwhelms them but
most people you made Randy's daughter
Rachael loveliest person little Randy a
complicated person with positive traits
you know I've spent time with with
diagnosed Psychopaths and in secured
units and found positive you know many
positive tricks with my new book so
you've been publicly shamed it's all
about that it's all about let's find
these people who we because we have the
power dog social justice people like me
there's five as people who we've decided
her are have no merit and and you know
because some tweets they have no merit
and and you know give them
their human qualities so their empathy
and passion I only tell stories that I
passionately want to tell and so I can
go to people and say look you know I and
I think the passion I think they can
feel it
well somebody you talk to about your new
book and is featured in your new book so
you've been publicly shamed let's watch
a little bit of video here and then
we'll come back and there are no
perimeters around how many people can
publicly observe you and put you in a
public stockade there is a very personal
price to public humiliation and the
growth of the Internet has jacked up
that price for nearly two decades now we
have slowly been sowing the seeds of
shame and public humiliation in our
cultural soil both on and offline gossip
websites paparazzi reality programming
politics news outlets and sometimes
hackers all traffic in shames it's led
to desensitization and a permissive
environment online which lends itself to
trolling invasion of privacy and
cyberbullying Jon Ronson yeah I love her
loud traffic again saying I and it's -
we are like on social media we are
sometimes feel that we like we like
unpaid shaming interns for Google and
Twitter like they're making good money
out of people savings and we're getting
nothing
in fact we're getting worse than nothing
we're contribution to a frightened old
conservative conformist Society yeah you
know I was talking about the weavers and
I was talking about the people being
demonized in my earlier book power
sisters and now right now at this moment
that people have the most power on
social media are people who convey much
from my world social justice people and
I think we're finding it
really hard to distinguish that
differentiates between serious
transgressions and unserious
transgressions and for somebody who
makes a joke that comes out badly
suddenly that person is being torn apart
their lives in Cataclysm because of the
foolish and erroneous belief that some
badly worded joke is a clue to that
person's inherent evil you know it's
labeling culture again which I write
about in psychopathic as I write about
it in them and I write about it in so
you've been publicly shamed this this
terrible ludicrous tendency we have as
human beings to want to define somebody
by their outermost aspect and we do it
in the mainstream media as well and it's
an it and we do it because it's because
it's fun and because it makes us feel
good it's like a kind of cathartic
alternative
real progress as somebody wrote about my
book and and we do it because as human
beings we love nothing more than to
declare other people insane and we do it
to make ourselves feel good and we do it
because on social media we surround
ourselves with people who feel the same
way we do so it becomes as colors mutual
approval machine my friend Ivan Curtis
the filmmaker cause of mutual grooming
like grooming each other and so people
at Monica Lewinsky or Justine Sacco in
my book become like data passed around
and this in this approval machine
because when we destroy somebody like
Justine Sacco and I think at some point
I should explain who it is who she is
and what she did everybody approves us
so that gives us our dopamine Russian
and you know we can we can show that
we're good empathetic people but in our
ferocious desire to be good empathetic
people the flame burns really hot and we
commit these incredibly unimpressive
acts like we did to poor Justine and is
there some schadenfreude illness and
this may be a little bit of
schadenfreude yeah I think there's also
the kind of drone strike operator
in us that we can just press the button
and continue happily with it with our
day don't need to think about the
village we've just smashed up and the
snowflakes doesn't need to feel
responsible for the Avalanche but I
think most of all I think it's the it's
the earnest desire to do good that's
where it's come from because we do do
good I mean just you know I mean you
know constantly good things happening
social justice is is is making enormous
inroads you know it's working we has
power if a columnist makes a racist
comment in a column we can punish the
newspaper and it was a way I mean
sometimes it is me sometimes it's other
people but it works there's power the
black lives matter protests that works
to an extent to this and there's there's
there's power there but we fall in love
with it so much that a day without a
shaming feels like a day treading water
picking fingernails and suddenly there's
a huge amount of collateral damage and I
wanted to write a book about the
collateral damage these people that we
now have demonized in here is a picture
of Justine Sacco arriving at the Cape
Town Airport who is just insect Justine
I really love Justine in my story
because one of the first things this
books been written about a lot you know
it's ended up in a lot of editorial was
much more than any of my other books and
one of the editorials said you know
Johnson so like so write a book about
you know mob mentality on social media
but why did he have to make Justine
Sacco a sympathetic character and when I
read that I I just dug my hills in all
the more because you know don't tell me
that I can write about that wronged
person but I'm not allowed to laugh
about this wronged person because of the
baggage that comes with her you know
someone's wronged
they're wronged so Justine had with a PR
woman New York City she had 170
to followers her avatar you know she
looks like she's good-looking she's
blonde she he evidently has fun at
parties in New York you know there's a
lot of people out there who immediately
that land cause you know misogynists and
so on so anyway she would she would
tweet little acerbic jokes to her
hundred and seventy twitter followers
and one of them the worst joke she ever
made and ever will make she was on her
way from new york to cape town by
Heathrow and she tweeted going to ask
the Kerr hope I don't get AIDS just
kidding
I'm white and so she's going to show
that to you on the air right now so so
she chuckled to herself breasts and
wandered around he throws half an hour
sporadically getting to it luckily
checking Twitter got no replies
I felt that sad feeling that we all feel
where the internet doesn't congratulate
us for being only when the New York
Times ran an extract in my book
the fact checker found her up and said
were you surprised to have got no
replies and she said I had 170 Twitter
followers I never got any replies
nobody ever talks back to me on the
internet and so she got on the plane
switched off her phone slept woke up 11
hours later at Cape Town turned on her
phone and straightaway there was a text
some somebody she hadn't spoken to since
high school that said I am so sorry to
see what's happening to you right now
and she looks a bit baffled and then
another text my best friend you need to
call me right away
you are the worldwide number one
trending topic on Twitter now the reason
why I said that she was roamed it's
because she didn't intend I mean yeah
like everybody else I was that lying and
bad everybody else on Twitter that that
I lay in bed and that tweet overwhelm at
an island because well she slept that
tweet word around the world everybody
from Gawker
with Donald Trump everybody was
retweeting it and everybody was united
in
oh you know this woman is a terrible
human being
and she was asleep on a plane and
oblivious to her destruction and that
was that became part of the hilarity
that she didn't know because her
employer said this is not rageous tweet
and clearly colored me unreachable on an
international flight so then it was like
oh man I can't wait for justine sacco to
land we're about to watch this just in
psycho [ __ ] get fired in real-time
before she even knows she's being fired
and much I mean you know trolls you know
hoping that she would be raped by
somebody HIV positive and then we'll
find out if their skin color protects
affirm eight nobody by the way went
after that person that person got a free
pass everybody was so excited and happy
to be tearing apart justine sacco that
nobody could handle the complexity of
tearing apart somebody who was
inappropriately tearing apart justine
that's how simple-minded our social
media shaming are you know this
cathartic alternative to real social
justice and the reason the other reason
might say she was roamed is because he
had not intended I mean I lay in bed and
looked at history too that my first
thought was like you know wow this is
exciting let's watch this person get
destroyed and then three seconds later I
thought I'm not sure that was intended
to be a racist tweet there's a tradition
of people doing this type of humor not
gleefully flaunting privilege but
mocking the gleeful flaunting of
privilege by making a kind of extreme
exaggerated version and Randy Newman's
short people got no reason to live
South Park Colbert you know maybe I
thought as I lay in bed maybe just in
psychos crime was not being as good as
it is landing England maybe that's why
her life is changing forever she's just
not very good at it
and when I did meet just in a couple of
weeks later at times she was just broken
I mean just crushed traumatized you know
trauma PTSD I asked her to explain the
joke and she said living in America
puts us in a bit of a bubble when it
comes to what's going on in the third
world and I was making fun snout bubble
somebody review my book actually woman
called Helen Lewis working for the New
Statesman at London she wrote in her
review that like me she was on Twitter
that now and she tweeted I'm not sure
that that joke was intended to be racist
and she said straight away she got this
kind of flurry of libel you're just a
privileged [ __ ] to and he said to her
shame she shut up you know we're
supposed earnest that as human beings
were supposed to stand up to the bullies
we're supposed to stand up to injustice
but people were just too afraid to stand
up to injustice with justine sacco and
that made me all the more all the more
pursuit and I had to do it did she want
to talk to you as but not at first
nobody wanted how could I was asking
people to relive these deeply wounding
haunting traumatizing moments in their
lives just being agreed to talk to me
she finally agreed to meet me about
three weeks after it happened that the
deal we had was I could take the
conversation but she would like defer
judgment as to were there she would let
me use it
so then a couple of months went by when
I was like you know cuddling the fingers
I then she decided that she didn't you
know she wanted just one time to get one
interview to show people just how insane
it was that me that the punishment was
so wildly disproportionate to the crime
and so then I met it again on the record
and both interviews became on the record
and then as the book was coming closer
and closer to publication she started to
regret talking to me and was like you
know if I could turn back the clock I
wouldn't have talked you she was really
nervous I could just go open it all up
again it's so painful you know to be
told because this isn't trolls I mean
trolls toilet practice day but it was it
was it was nice people there was
hundreds of thousands of nice good
people told Justine that she was
worthless and she had to get out of that
that is a deeply traumatized thing so
anyway then the New York Times extract
came out and she emailed me and said I
am so glad that you told my story you
know she felt such a relief that I told
the story the way it should be called
what's she doing her she's got a new job
in public relations this is after lucky
buddy year crushed and in the wilderness
so she's got a new job in public
relations she's she's she's dating again
she couldn't date for a while because it
had just been Socko and what do you get
you know racist aid to eat woman
Google's dinner doesn't skirt but she's
dating again and she's fine now and
happy a lot of people said to her after
the book came out you know IKEA I can't
believe what we did as you know buddy
said I can't believe what we did to you
a huge number of people so I can't
believe what those people go to you and
then I got a battle ash like so first it
was like all you know drugs billion so
it's and passionate and kind to be doing
the story this way and then said it was
like a backlash against me and it was
like what a number one comment said what
racist is what racist is Jon Ronson
going to put his cape on for next so but
and then I mean I mentioned these kind
of extreme ones because it sort of
benefits me because in the ID you
mentioned the more ludicrous ones net
insisted to be on my side so I realized
that I'm slightly biased to have in the
ones I'm hands picking is because I they
suit me
but the other one that I remember I
didn't reply to any of them because
actually I just like one thing when the
New York Times expert came out and this
backlash started I will by the way this
isn't a standalone article it's an
extract from my book so you've been
publicly shamed and I saw a bunch of
people tweeted oh now Jon Ronson say
gets an extract from a book every one of
our baby with always a text it's always
a really girl that ran her look quickly
wrote a book like a couple
and then I only know buddy replied and
that didn't apply to anybody and then
somebody tweeted and license or not so
applying to any of us and then somebody
else wrote because John Munson only
replies to men so then I remembered
something that one of my other
interviewee
said to me in the book he said I have to
remember that I am just a blank canvas
for people to put their ideologies onto
and at that moment I realized I was a
blank canvas for people to put raviolis
on well I also realized something
I realize have made it have two types of
people in the world that the people who
values humans over ideologies and
there's a type of people who value
ideology of the humans I don't know
maybe that's too to binary and
simplistic but if there are those two
types of people in the world I'm under
finish tag and you're watching book TV
on c-span 2 48 hours of nonfiction books
and authors every weekend and this is
our in-depth program once a month we
invite one author on to talk about his
or her body of work and this month it is
best-selling author Jon Ronson Jon
Ronson first wrote a book in 1994 and
it's called club class we'll ask him
about that in just a minute
them bestseller came out in 2001 the men
who stare at goats came out in 2004 and
of course that became a movie the
psychopath test a journey through the
madness industry came out in 2011 and
that is being made into a movie lost at
sea the Jon Ronson mysteries 2012 Frank
the true story that inspired the movie
you can see the cover there just came
out last year and this year his most
recent book is so you've been publicly
shamed what is club class mr. Ronson you
make a face every time the producer told
me that you made had made a noise when
we asked you about that and we made a
face again like a child in my attic
I in the early 90s I made a TV series
for the BBC called the Ronson mission I
was really young I was like early
twenties
and completely unprepared negativity
series I'd also hate Allah hates of
everything about it and the little
cameras hadn't been invented so you turn
up with these giant cameras and that I
was a journalist then I was you know so
there I was an actor I wasn't a
journalist anymore I've been comfortable
anyway the series was a terrible flop
and I was I was cut up in the wilderness
in my mid-twenties and the only offer of
work I was given was was to write a book
really fast like in three months
and for Christmas and I just look called
blood glass so the idea was that I would
like I'm gonna have such a young person
thing and I feel embarrassed
am i used i the idea was to kind of blog
my way around the world in this kind of
five-star way so I tried get myself like
three trips on on the qe2 and I went I
went to Zimbabwe ended up on a big-game
hunt the most exciting thing that
happened was I ended up in a in a mini
war in Baku tips wanna in South Africa
it was when the AWP I did people
remember this when the AWB using
Terblanche with neo-nazi group it was
just around the time the election
Mandela was just about to get elected
and these three neo-nazis ended up in a
space called pocket it's Lana near Sun
City the big casino I'm were killed and
and I was I was there so I was like
stranded in Sun City with this war so
that's kind of exciting but but it was
just I mean I get the answer on my voice
I I just you know in the absence of
having my own voice I was just trying to
be PJ O'Rourke or Huntress Thompson or a
British version of those people Victor
Lewis left I saw just had be there
that's lying bastard by the book because
it wasn't my voice you know I first
found my voice my voice when I was I
think damning 2001 we want to put the
numbers up because in depth is a calling
program if you
like to have a conversation with Jon
Ronson here the numbers 202 is the area
code 7 4 8 8200 if you live in the east
and central time zones seven four eight
eight two zero one for those of you
Mountain and Pacific and further out in
Hawaii as well and book TV at c-span dot
o-r-g is our email address if you can't
get through on the phone lines or you
can send a tweet at book TV and finally
you can make a comment on our Facebook
page facebook.com slash c-span he'll be
with us for another 2 hours and 15
minutes mr. Ronson what's a psychopath
is there a definition yeah according to
Robert hare who's like the the master of
this that they you know man invented the
pcl our checklist it's it's a tech list
of 20 chase I could probably name or 20
I see how many I can name without
stopping to think like of empathy lack
of remorse grandiose self-worth glibness
superficial charm impulsivity
responsibility cunning manipulative the
main one is lack of empathy there's a
kind of neurological absence of empathy
according to air there's there's other
psychologists including a amazing man I
met sir so you've been publicly shown
called James Gilligan who has a you has
got a different view on this but but
according to her there's like a kind of
me you know there's a better
neurological absence of empathy that
kind of makes them different to other
human beings where there should be
empathy this kind of twisted forest
grows these are the malevolent character
traits like you know grandiose self
self-worth and so on the reason why I
stumbled on the story and one who drives
book about Psychopaths was because of a
totally different story that I was doing
for my BBC Radio 4 Series about this
woman I forgot yoga ages
goblet elitist versus believer like
forgot time
I did I made a story about this woman
chimera Tina Thompson this all started
and this isn't in the box bad way she
was internet dating and she met a guy
who will jordan ave khaled gallant man
so gallant that he would he know he'd
hold the door open for her by a flowers
walk on the road side of the sidewalk
which I didn't even know was like a
thing okay uh-huh
I don't even know that was like a
gallant thing I've I guess if you really
think about it and I mean I'm so bad at
Gallegly I should tell you that like I I
opened a door for somebody like way too
early and they have to like break into
like a new slightly embarrassed run so
anyway we'll Jordan was vague Allen and
they fell in love and she was about to
marry him and that he said in realize I
I don't know anything about this guy I'm
about to marry so she looked him up on
Companies House and didn't work if
there's an American equivalent companies
house but you can find out stuff about
people so she discovered he had this
other house that she didn't know about
and so she was so like Miss Marple she
drove to it and it was this mansion near
the sea near Edinburgh and so she
confronted him and he went into another
room and his talks on the phone and he
came back and he said okay I can tell
you said I work eight American hey but I
work from CIA and about how she stumbled
upon it our safe house and you know okay
and and showed her various documentation
to prove it and so on so for the next
seven years she was married to him and
he golfed like Jeanine and he'd get
these like messages from the CIA saying
is find and I was in hospital but he
spine I thought this seven years of this
she got a call one day saying are you
mrs. Jordan and Rubin said yes
and he said I'm the other mrs. Jordan
and it turned out that he wasn't working
CIA he was a bigamist and the house and
Golan was his other wife and his other
family and he was a bigger mess than a
pedophile and frauds there so I came
across her story because I wanted to
write a story about the victims of cons
so I said to our brilliant producer the
social I work with Lucy Greene well can
you find me some victims of cons and she
found Mary but I was talking to Mary
about all of this I said I said he must
have been incredibly upset and she said
no he's a psychopath and so you know
does the wildebeest feel upset when it's
being chased by the lion and I thought
wow I've never ever thought of the world
that way before
and then I talked to this psychologist
called Martha stout who wrote this book
called the sociopath next door and she
said yeah she said you know not only do
they exist but is that way more of them
than you think and and this was that the
kicker for me said they did they rule
the world and I said what are you
telling me - there's this particular
mental disorder that's so powerful that
it's like remoulded Society or Rome she
said yes had capitalism rewards
psychopathic character traits you are
much more likely to have a psychopath at
the top of the tray like the head of
your business then you are and I
remember Center this is this like this
is a huge thought you know this is like
if you think about this this is like a
huge thought and she was but yes it's a
huge thought so then I got felt stuck
with me and then I started talking this
is all like the preamble to right and
none of this is really in the
psychopathy test it's all that the
preamble to be writing the book so then
I started talking to this psychologist
called Kevin Dustin who's spent time
with Psychopaths and I think he told me
about Robert hare
oh and then I started reading the DSM
because I got really interested in
labeling and disor witch's Albion Manual
of Mental Disorders used to be a
pamphlet back in the fifties space you
but the filters back then little
pamphlet ma'am house you know that was
bigger than the biggest book of yourself
over there it's eight hundred and eighty
six pages long currently lists the dsm-4
list 374 disorders having dsm-5 got even
more they've added a few took one or two
out
cook-out Asperger's bad it bunch of
others so so I thought this is
extraordinary through the DSM friend's
house and I suggested all these things
like I qualified a sly generalized
anxiety disorder which frankly you know
forgiven but also parent-child relation
or problems
I thought yep arithmetic learning
disorder as I yes respect nightmare
disorder which is got a categorized if
you have like recovered dreams of being
pursued or declared a failure which is
basically sums up all of my dreams and
it's also keep it as long as it's real
you know wow yeah and Beth and then I
thought okay either I'm much closer to
no suicides or maybe it's not a good
idea to diagnose yourself with mental
disorders we're not a trained
professional or maybe the psychiatric
profession has as a strange desire to
label what's essentially normal human
behavior is mental disorders I don't
know which one of those things is true I
did notice though that psychopathy
wasn't in the DSM it looks like
Psychopaths aren't in there not Noah
sociopath but what is in there is
antisocial personality disorder so that
sort of vaguely piqued my interest like
I wonder why and then I forgot about it
so then I thought I shouldn't worry at
all about just going on right that's the
purpose of okay good so then I thought
I'd quite like to meet some critics of
Psychiatry you know now I've got all
these labels incentivate may be sort of
fun
- I read something in half is a really
great piece in Harper's kind of mocking
labeling culture at the DSM and that's
that I got luck to me so critic of
Psychiatry to get their point of view so
I ended up having lunch with the
Scientologists who have a crack team of
of psychiatry destroyers called the cchr
so I'd lunch with E what are the heads
of the British leg Brian and who I was
really you could imagine how nervous I
was tuned up for lunch because you know
there's so many stories about you know
strong-arm tactics in fact a friend of
mine Louis Theroux who makes similar
documentaries to me he's been making the
documentary about the Scientologists and
now the Scientologists making a
documentary about him they found
everyone on Twitter was like god I'm by
my much more excited about seeing the
Scientologist he'll eventually about
Louis and Louis docuventary was so
intelligent so I was that really nervous
that me but actually I got on quite well
with Brad you know he didn't you know
there was no pressure and I said to him
you know okay prove it now proved to me
your view that psychiatry is like a
wicked pseudoscience that can't be
trusted and he said okay I can prove it
to you and I said how and I said I can
introduce you to Tony so I said who's
Tony and it had toad is in Broadmoor
which is bored more Hospital you know in
the old days it was known as the board
will asylum for the criminally insane I
said what did Tony do and Brian said
hardly anything
he beat somebody up or something but
that's not the point yet the point is
that he faked madness to get out of a
prison sentence and now he's stuck in
Broadmoor and nobody will believe he's
sane do you want us to try and get you
into Broadmoor to meet Tony so I said
yes please
so Brian did something of Scientologists
a really good app which is circumvent
bureaucracy and got me into Gordon or
the million behind turned after World
War I had to say I was a scholar instead
of a journalist which I thought would
sort of fake be ridiculous
but then a little bit because yeah so we
turned up at Broadmoor and the guy on
the desk was really funny and cheerful
it went you know have you got good
you know have you got a phone a cake
with a hacksaw inside so he's not making
jokes and then oh my god and then we I'm
telling you Lightwood more than than
it's in the book then we were like cept
put into this kind of waiting area
between security fences with this woman
and an LA I said Julito we use here to
see and she said both of my sons were
here and later on I saw her so sad I
dressed up like Sunday lunch at the
Sunday lunch time and she was I dressed
up in like her best clothes to see her
two boys both locked up and ordinal and
she was ready laughs see them one at a
time
a stiffer side anyway so we got taken
through me and Bryan into the into the
place where you get to meet the patients
which is called a Wellness Center and
Bryan said to me you know Tony's the
only person in the entire dspd unit to
have Commission to meet people in the
Wellness Center so I said what does dspd
stand for and he said dangerous and
severe personality chiseled yeah but a
lot of tell you in the part of Bravo the
how it was like the most dangerous
people and yeah it's not crazy so then
the patient started arriving I know all
quite overweight and wearing sweatpants
they can look like they've given up you
know and and then remember Brad
whispered today's event medicated which
the Brian is a Fanta licious is like the
worst thing I then Brian said oh here's
Tony and the guy was walking towards me
and he was wearing a suit of pinstripe
suits and he had it arm outstretched
like somebody hardly apprenticed and it
was evidently the outfit of somebody
wanted to convince me that he was very
sane but he sat down and because after
as I said to Brian you know but a year
later I said God you know
Uganda is the best no thank you the best
I sat down and I said is it true that
you sakes you a in here and he said yes
so I beat somebody up when I was 17 and
my cell mates been reading and my cell
mate said to me you're looking at five
to seven years in prison what you need
to do is fake madness and tell him
you're mad you'll get sent to some cushy
Hospital you have your PlayStation
nurses or bring your pizzas so how did
you do it he said well I am I asking
prison psychiatrist he said Majesty the
film called crash in which people get
sexual pleasure from crashing cars into
walls so I said I get sexual pleasure to
come crashing cars into walls
Alessandro knows is that oh I told the
prison psychiatrist that I wanted to
watch women as they died because it
would make me feel more normal such a
where do you get that from Hillel from a
biography of Ted Bundy that they had to
the prison library he said anyway turns
out I faked madness to well they didn't
send me some cushy Hospital percent with
her Broadmoor that the minute I got here
I said there's been a terrible
misunderstanding
I said how long's he been here for still
if I just gone to prison for the for the
DBH grievous bodily harm I'd have got
five to seven years I've been in
Broadmoor for 12 years I could he said
it's much harder to convince people that
you're sane than it is to convince them
that you crazy like you'd like to stay
away from the other patients because he
found them quite frightening
I get the Stockwell strangler on one
side of him and the tiptoe through the
tulips latest on the other side of him
so he stayed in his room a lot Adi said
he sold his medical notes that they
wrote you know only and Gordon law would
not wanted to hang out with serial
killers suicide of madness tender he
said like he that one way he tried to
convince him that he was sailing was
just to talk to them about normal things
like football he said I thought you'd do
right and I'm like gasps and he said I
subscribe to New Scientist he said it
was masculine New Scientist at
out how they were training bumblebees to
sniff out explosives so I said to the I
said to the psychiatrist that I said to
the nurse did you know that the training
bumblebees to sniff out explosives and I
said I thought that they wrote in my
medical notes believes bees can sniff
out explosives so everything you did to
try to convince them that he was sane
made him seem more crazy he said how do
you sit in the same way you know how do
you cross your legs in the same way that
the more yourself consisted where you
come over he's like nuts and fell ill I
left girl North and he seemed that
completely normal to me but again what
did I know
so it was clinician man good Anthony
made him since left Broadmoor and I said
what story and he won't market he said
we accept that
Tony story is true we accept that he
faked madness together a prison sentence
because you know his delusions you
seemed a cliche to begin with just
vanish the man is he got two gold more I
said however he's been assessed and
we've determined that what he is is a
psychopath and is that faking madness is
exactly the kind of cunning and
manipulative act of a psychopath on the
test list coming manipulative and then
the other collision says we like you
know how think the pinstripe suits
classic psychopath speaks to like
grandiose sense of self-worth one of the
items on the checklist and so all the
things that seem most normal about Tony
was evidence according to his clinicians
that he was psychopaths and then one of
them said and he's gonna know more he
could you know contact Robert hare who's
like you know there's the master of this
stuff so I did I phoned Robert hare and
we had a number of conversations that
eventually Robert hare said to me you
should come on one of my courses so I
did and was a three-day course where he
taught clinicians and so on how to UM
you know identify you know how to use a
checklist
responsibly and so I did and had a
1-point hair said to me you know what
frustrates me so much is the fact that
there's a huge story here and its
corporate psychopathy and why's nobody
interested and nobody was interested
about
I mean I've thought of it but like with
the Bilderberg Group in them I kind of
popularized the idea of people thinking
about corporate psychopathy in the
psychopathy test and then I think a lot
of people went to to love it hares books
after that like snakes and suits he said
this is the biggest story in the world
he said basically Martha started said to
me like you know why the wars why the
injustice corporate Psychopaths he said
you should really try and find yourself
some corporate Psychopaths doing to do
so I did I wrote to Bernie Madoff and I
said can I come an interview in prison
to find out if you're a psychopath
and he didn't write back and then I
changed tack I I took a leaf from the
psychopath checklist I became more
cunning manipulative I I looked at all
Dunlap chainsaw al Dunlap the famous
assets differ from the nineties and I
said I believe you may have a very
special brain anomaly that makes you
feel less interested in the predatory
spirit can I come and interview you
about your special brain normally and he
said come on over in el Dunlap of course
is here
the gentleman who headed Sunbeam
corporation for a while and you can if
you read the psychopathy test the
subtitle and journey through the madness
industry you can find out what happened
to Tony in the end but this is what you
write about Robert here and then we're
going to go to phone calls Robert hare
is influential Justice Department's and
parole boards all over the world have
accepted his contention that psychopaths
are quite simply incurable and everyone
should concentrate their energies
instead on learning how to root them out
using his pcl - our checklist which he
has spent a lifetime refining is that is
that indicative of the industry part of
your subtitle also yeah the book about
halfway through the book it takes this
huge shift I become after doing the hair
course I become drunk with my
Psychopaths box in college I started
thinking about all the people in my past
who had crossed me
to determine which of them I could
Elsa's Psychopaths so like you know
critics we've given my television
documentaries bad reviews thought and
I'm blind to it blind to my biases what
I went to see our Dunlap I like he like
I went through the checklist with him
and and but when he said no certain
things like he said no too many
short-term outer relationships he's ever
been married twice he said no to
juvenile delinquency he got accepted
into West Point and my guess is that
they don't let delinquents into West
Point about assume and so he said no -
he emphatically said no to a bunch of
things I remember being out Dunlap's
house and thinking well that's ok I
won't put that in the book and it dawned
on me wow you know I'm so drunk with my
psychopath but in colleges Gallet only a
little bit psychopathic and then the
second half of the book is about the can
of the more can a tyrannical side of
labeling so how children as young as 2/3
in America are getting labeled owes
bipolar because they score high on the
bipolar checklist because they're
presented with temper tantrums you know
a little girl died Rebecca Riley her
name was four years old died because her
parents gave her an overdose of
anti-psychotic medication she being
diagnosed with bipolar disorder and like
the age of two you know unbelievable so
that's what I mean what I mean industry
none of this by the way is to impugn
Robert hare who are who has spent a
lifetime developing this checklist which
is a you know a serious thing but her
sense of me
you know people come in my course and he
says this is like a real burden people
come in my course and doodle pick their
fingernails and then go back and have
power over whether to keep somebody you
know in terms beyond their prison
sentence because they score higher a
checklist and my checklist and you know
what happened to me was was that I
became so the second half
it's really a cautionary tale to not do
what I do in the first half of the book
so that's what I'm talking about my book
might be interesting I think with this
book you know this book is about the
gray area between the on the one extreme
the DSM people and on the other extreme
the Scientologists and my book is about
the gray area didn't lies between with
him what's the thread amongst all your
books I think I think it's about power
an especially when power becomes absurd
and when people inside bubbles of power
commit absurd or appalling acts but all
of that from a position of humanism and
empathy so it's all unkindness and
compassion and as Mother kolinsky said
in and her TED talk dimensionality so
it's trying to humanize these inhuman
situations so until you've been publicly
shamed my job is so long you know we are
now the people in the bubble you know
calling Justine Sacco
you know these terrible words because we
want to destroy or not feel bad about it
we and other people in that bubble and
so my job is to both humanize her and us
you know to explore this clash between
power and humanity and absurdity in a
way that doesn't repeat the mistakes
that brings empathy back into the
situation let's hear from America we're
going to begin with Christopher and
Nashville Tennessee you're on with Jon
Ronson on book TV Christopher Haigh hi
I'm thank you for taking my call I was
calling because your story at the
beginning obviously seems like it you
were talking about people in power and I
was wondering what your thoughts were on
it's been you know there's documentaries
and a lot of talks for in America about
Illuminati controlling the media and
Hollywood and I've read some stories of
even European powers what you think on
that and
my second part of the question my second
part of the discussion I want to talk
about with you talk about people with
power and I just as recently reading
about after the USSR collapsed and the
oligarchs that came in and most of them
were Jewish people and I've noticed a
lot of Jewish not so much practicing
Jews of the religion but part of their
identity as yours people taking control
and major media outlets and in major
government platforms and I was running
on your statement on those two issues
well if it's something that I was
talking to my son about this this
yesterday we haven't come to face like
this because he was on a was on one of
the protests yesterday in New York and
no no it wasn't happening I'll forget
about that he was talking to somebody
after the protest so I'm nothing to do
with the protest so we're talking about
like the Rothschilds as the dosa
Sicilian who are the roster and I'm like
I thought hey okay here's the problem
there's a lot of power families in the
world it always be a little bit
suspicious of of people are kind of
focusing on the Rothschilds you know who
happened to be one of the Jewish power
families now when people talk about
Hollywood power and so on this is okay
this is sometimes a euphemism for Jews
and it gets quite quickly into into
anti-semitism and you know because
throughout history people you know
anti-semites have considered the
Illuminati to be kind of Jewish
conspiracy this goes back to the
protocols of the Elders of Zion that's
Ford's Silas document if you read the
protocols of Zion if it's ridiculous
it's like it's supposed to be like the
secret minute of a secret Jewish meeting
and I'm a minute so things like the
weapon get our hands are merciless
vengeance greed we will not rest until
we've established our international
super government if I can you honestly
think Hitler could you honestly imagine
a secret
you know the weapons that I hands of
merciless vengeance you know still
people believe this stuff people bleep
and to actually did say that so I you
know I am I'm always very suspicious
power exists secret groups exist whether
it build a big group if you want to
actually say how many are dues almost
none like you know Bohemian Grove almost
notice is that how you share that told
me the comedian told me that the reason
why he was invited to a Bohemian Grove
was to this is his words to do the place
up because they were like so few Jews it
was kind of embarrassing the fact is
there is power
and there are powerful cables and there
are powerful families but when you start
to talk about you know Hollywood it gets
to be say quickly to come code words for
anti-semitism and in one of your books I
forget which one may be them you go to
Hollywood
yeah exactly the I hug around with a
Teddy K the bureau's filmmaker you know
he's the one with the limousine that was
curated on the 1f8 yeah he was making
this film called American History X and
they were trying to nestle the film from
him because he wouldn't leave the edit
he'd be next thing it'd feel like you
know ten years or something and he
wouldn't leave and so he invited a rabbi
he decided to go see the head of the
film company new line films and he
brought with him a rabbi a Catholic
priest and a Tibetan monk and he was
taking them all with him to this meeting
with new line and he wanted a man but he
can find one when wind go so anyway it
was kind of a bad thing because the
rabbi just wanted to pictures movie
ideas and I was very good I know it
didn't work at all and Edward Norton
finish the movie I do talk about cold
words though in the thing I'm in the
anti-defamation league who's obviously
who obviously on my side of the fence
they go a little bit code would crazy
sometimes so maybe you know Hollywood
you know that last call
it shows that some people do use code
words that are euphemisms for such as a
meal that we actually said Jewish as
well but also but I asked the
anti-defamation league for their kind of
list of code words and it was kind of
crazy like the New Yorkers the middlemen
in New York the globally send you know
traffic they've got it overly generous
dictionary of code words the Jews
because it sort of suits their agenda
that debacle droids Matthew is in
Lansing Michigan Matthew thanks for
holding
you're on with Jon Ronson hi I was
wondering what mister Anton's opinion is
and why so many horrible people make so
many despicable comments on the internet
and yet people like Justine Sacco are
punished horribly for what they've said
yeah it's it's Li thank you so much for
that comment it's it's it's so
ridiculous that I mean it happened the
other day with this woman Brits McHenry
that her name is the ESPN woman who does
discover you know her cars impounded so
she goes to the car pal to get her car
out and launches into this car is you
know horrible tirades like you know I'm
better-looking the new kind of an
entitlement tirade
yeah yeah and because you have these
days the most shame would be offence
rightly for many reasons
is the misuse of privilege misuse of
entitlements which of course is a much
better thing to to get upset about than
the things people used to get shameful
like adultery and but the problem is
that the word privilege is being bandied
around that you would privileges are
being used to get everybody through
everything you know suggesting even at
170 Twitter followers an unknown PR
woman in New York she was destroyed for
the misuse of privilege
so I'm so but in Brit McKenna's case you
know yes you know she she told up and
said these incredibly entitled things
I've got better teeth than you I've got
better hair than you I'm on television
and Brittles like the worst thing for
delicious at it with all film going and
they released the video but of course
what happened is they're like in
punishing her those are some social
media so like loud terrible you know you
said you should have seen what people
are writing to her was like yeah I'm
going to rape you I'm going to moody I'm
going to cut out your uterus about and
censoring the things like I'm I can
remember here so you know we we punish
people with exactly the same
transgression so that's I got to get
itself and I think you know it's like
hey this is not somebody from a Boston
Magazine it's such a beautiful line said
about my book but so you've been
publicly shamed said you know this isn't
social justice it's a cathartic
alternative to social justice you know
just it you know what they did to Justin
Sacher was a cathartic alternative to
social justice it makes you feel like
you Rosa Parks but you're not his Rosa
Parks did something courageous tearing
apart a woman on a plane as she slept
it's not courageous however in the six
the six cop yes the six cops who were
arrested yesterday or the day before
yesterday the guy whose film said you
know thank God for the film didn't put
it online thank God for social media and
yes I've got for social media this is
what we should be doing but now the
power is in our hands it's incumbent
upon us to know how to differentiate
between a serious transgression and
serious transgression because right now
all we're doing is create well what that
was well as doing proper good work we
are also creating a surveillance society
where lives are getting ruined routinely
and one of the people who repeat my book
most of the reviews have been really
positive but one negative review
basically said I you know it's all it's
fine you know a little spine ELISA
somebody who was used to be the editor
of gorko sly Cardini all these meta
Joneses look there find another it's not
a big get beaten up in real life is bad
you know business of this is fine you
know it doesn't hurt at all
I I went around the world for three
years meeting
people who had been destroyed on social
media for transgressions sometimes more
serious transgression sometimes nothing
it's not fine get mangled people's
mental health I met people who were
suffering insomnia depression suicidal
thoughts waking up in bed and that's
forgetting who you are disassociating
from your body
Nido post-traumatic stress disorder
agony but when you are when you are the
objects of a shaming those feelings are
visible to the shamers something
happened to me a couple of weeks ago
where a line the Magali of my block
which was taken out before that was
published somebody tweeted it out of
context and they'd be like that worse
and it was and I was kind of up all
night worrying about it
not cuz I wanted to be but because you
know my anxiety went crazy and the next
thing I said you know it goes to show
that I you know what an impact on your
mental health kind of social media shame
in hers and somebody somebody tweeted me
stop whining so it's like if you are the
object of a shaming you know any
feelings that you have a visible and
that's why I wanted to write a book
which hemolyzed because I'm reading this
what the best compliment this book has
had it a number of times as people say
it's like watching a horror movie your
heart is pounding you feel what it feels
like to be at the end of a social media
shame and you feel what it feels like to
be justine sacco
you know it's dreadful it's dread and
they also by the way in case anybody
watching this things I'm not good about
population such a great page-turner and
funny too but that's what I wanted to do
with this book is make people feel that
dread and and I because I think it's
much harder to order the steak once you
visited snow south Eaton Brooklyn good
afternoon you're on with John ransom ice
that's a ton well thank you mr. Roslyn
sourced Oh Alice Lee is it
I think you're one of the most decent
people in public life today in writing
Wow and I have a question about the
Mideast and the emotional pull to take
extreme positions and I would just be I
would just love to hear whatever you
have to say oh my god laughs thank you
thank you you know I mean I wanted to do
a bulleted is to do an israel-palestine
story along for a long time I did do a
story in Israel a couple of years ago
but it wasn't that good I was doing the
story I did a story about astroturf
thing about how you know governments
will will pretend to be kind of social
media people and spread positive
messages about the end the unpopular
corporations it wasn't a good story I
don't have much to say because I've
never I've never been to Gaza or the
West Bank what I would say is that I've
often wanted to I feel like I'd be a
good person to do it because I've got
like no axe to grind you know I'm not a
polemicist I'm a Jew who feels no
kinship to the State of Israel but I am
a Jew and the South often thought maybe
I should do that story that's really all
I can say about it were you raised in
the face yeah an Orthodox synagogue for
some reason my pen cordis in Cardus yeah
my great-grandfather was on his way to
New York and ran out of money in Cardiff
and so stopped that so so I thought in
Carrodus and yeah for some reason my
friends even though they forgive me all
the kind of cool Jewish teenagers went
to the reformed synagogue I had to go to
the Orthodox one where to be you know
hit themselves and weld stuff and do it
all in Hebrew when I discovered that I
could have basically done my vomit
through an English
so example what certain years of Hebrew
school from nothing the first Sunday
morning
I mean least I didn't have to go like
three times a week like some of the
other kids at the Orthodox synagogue but
I never never experienced any
anti-semitism in quor'toth none except
for the fact that the the man who taught
me my vomit sir was was murdered a
couple of years later by by a neighbor
of his who wouldn't his method and bad I
never experienced any anti-semitism
above my school which is kind of a you
know relatively tough local
comprehensive is that I would sometimes
smuggle the tough kids from the school
into the synagogue to show them what it
was like in there and it was kind of
impressive to them because it was so
kind of weird and you know but then when
I was 13 14 I started going to the forum
synagogue oh I remember one time I went
to the Jewish lads Brigade and we played
this game and it would like capture the
flag like yeah I were learning to a
field and capturing a flag and we want
to sit down and the guy said damn so are
you you would Israelis the flag of a
wall that's that's black catching so
then I started going to Reform synagogue
youth like summer camp and winter camp
and I was like the best time of my
teenage years go Daris why and and
hanging out with girls and so cool and
and so I never village I'm never
religious I may be I've never believed a
word of it ever you know even as I sang
my bar mitzvah I didn't believe a word
of what I was singing and but loved and
continue to love cool you know Jewish
people did you ever get to know
Christopher Hitchens before he died I
did no no never did Nina Nellie tweets
in is it fair that Google search after a
public shaming allow shamers to command
top billing on search result
okay here's the thing about I mean no
I'm good Google somebody said to me when
I was writing this book you know Google
has a kind of informal corporate motif
of don't be evil but Google makes money
out of anything that happens whether
it's good or bad
I asked I I works with some economists
to estimate how much money Google made
the mag adjusting psychos shaming
because in November 2013 15 was googled
40 times in December 2013
between December the 20th in the end of
the month she was googled 1 million two
hundred twenty thousand times so we
worked out using mathematics there I
can't quite remember now that Google was
several million dollar no knows who was
it was a lot less it that doesn't like I
would let the most was half a million
and I think the conservative numbers
like $120,000 or something like that
yeah you've got it in your book so
you've been publicly shamed they look
forward a minute ago but yeah I couldn't
find my mark so we'll go on to Barbara
in Seattle Barbara you're on with Jon
Ronson hi I want to ask him a question
do you think that the CIA and the US
government is more psycho or less cycle
than Ted Bundy I happen to live next
door to a person who drove across my
state with Ted Bundy and he would not
kill any woman with children um Wow um
certainly one was with the Randy Weaver
story that was a story that was in why
you would feel very hard-pressed will
you tell us though that the way that I
did to not feel incredibly sympathetic
towards the weavers and incredibly
unsympathetic towards the people who saw
Vicky Weiser while she stood unarmed in
her doorway holding her baby and we know
that
this kind of stuff happens a lot in in
my book the men who stare at goats I
write it's you know meso goats as comic
but I suppose it does it looks in its
way at this kind of stuff about how
inside that bubble people convince
themselves that you know atrocious axial
okay like kiddo like these extreme
interrogation techniques at Guantanamo
Bay and other grave and so on and more
psycho than Ted Bundy aside is obviously
a big lovely big race and the two things
are presumably different what the reason
why I've stopped and my own I've slowed
down is because of course this thing
goes back to what hare says and what
Marcus felt says which is that you will
feel oh that psychopathy is so powerful
that it revolves institutions to become
more psychopathic and I got back and
forward on it if you want my honest feel
like this I go back and forward on that
I think that there's certainly some
truth to it the men of the items on the
psychopathy checklist are rewarded in
business and politics and sports and so
on grandiose sense self-worth lack of
empathy lack of remorse and so on these
things are rewarded then some stuffs I
think or maybe it's it maybe it's a bit
too glib in a bit to labeling to label
the CIA as a psychopathic organization
out that also that also feels kind of
glib so so you know I'm so that I just
sort of slowed out it didn't have like
it easy answer but it's because I swing
back and forth on that nikki is in
Scottsdale Arizona hi Nikki wow this is
just wonderful I think he's he's a
prophet for this field thank you
same I find that he did in the
a work on this areas as a science we
need to bring all the other sciences to
work with you that it is organizational
development group dynamics it is all but
you are putting your hand on the
startups do you know how much they are
suffering from psychopaths do you know
how many families in the east of Turkey
and Israel and in Middle East they are
suffering from the mothers and aunts
with the Psychopaths and movies how to
rule for the power connecting themselves
to the power to survive you are just
fresh air but you need to talk about
more remedies and Seagal came up with
the with the mindfulness training I
decided later in my aged after shaking
hands five million people and putting
good fees in there for peace and all the
good things you will bring awareness now
I want to be a mystic all right Nicky
we're going to leave it there and hear
from mr. ronnson yeah well thank you
once again word that came out of that
which I which rubber bear with me with
the word mindfulness I've decided that
the next time I'm in need of therapy and
kind of go for mindfulness because
people swear diet so I'm going to give
mine for what is amazing you know I may
be somebody controlled in answer that
question it it's this new thing that's
kind of sweeping this the therapy world
and it's different CBT and it doesn't
involve medication and everyone's going
oh my god it's amazing if you've got OCD
you've got to try mindfulness and that
maybe somebody else maybe a mindfulness
therapist can give a very brief and soda
and give a very brief explanation of
exactly what it is Lily and Miami please
go ahead with your question or comment I
don't answer plain what mindfulness is
hello I'm so happy to be on your program
it's like the previous caller said a
breath of fresh air my question would be
someone that has been dealing with the
emotional quote unquote issues in our
family for a very long time by now I'm
struggling with a 18
grandson who's been labeled and
undiagnosed and diagnosed to death and
he struggling right now to find a way
how to navigate his journey right now
with the help of parents who are
well-meaning and grandparents who love
Him that are lost because we've been
misdirected in so many areas from the
education system to the justice system
and can I ask diagnosed with I'm going
to submit the pieces and sort of them
initially but I don't hold that to any
standard because no one has ever really
you know confirmed or given me a reason
to believe that it is true it may well
be but I suspect that so many other
things involved in coming to a
conclusion on what people are and why
they came to be who they are what ages
in what ages is the gun table 18 and
saying I'm sorry for the you know I'm
sorry for the troubles that you've been
going through I mean there's there's
undoubtedly an epidemic of of labeling
and other diagnoses going on well you
write in the psychopathy test I think
that first of all how they come up with
these diagnoses who's who comes up with
them and then often the loudest person
in the room he is the one who oh it's
extraordinary I said so the reason why
the DSM went something that big to big
that big is is all because of a man
called Robert Spitzer so his mother was
very unhappy lived and happy died and
happy went from food in like wine lists
of rhodium circle analysts and nobody
helped and dal-soo listen the psychopath
test and and then she died and Spitzer
grew up with this hatred of fraud in
psychotherapy and you know listing
around the unconscious and so what he
took over the DSM became a psychiatrist
when he took over the DSM he decided to
basically eradicate Freud from
psychiatry and with
play set with something more scientific
or at least scientific sounding like
like checklists I think he was inspired
by like psychologists like Robert hare
who was doing this stuff earlier like
you know can you identify you know
instead of like searching around for
these kind of mystical reasons
checklists so he hired a room at
Columbia and four years would invite
like-minded people and it's bad isn't it
IOC to the zoo guiding a Gilad there you
know ADHD goes once it's in plastic
litter and he liked - it's like a
typewriter and that's how ADHD came to
be in the DSM bulimia I said to Spitzer
were there any proposed mental disorders
that you that you said notice because
the other was one he said that a typical
child syndrome it's a problem with when
I asked the man proposing it what the
shared characteristics were he said well
that's very hard to say because two
children a very atypical
is that the other one was masochistic
personality disorder and it was women
who stayed at abusive relationships and
he said but I got I got totally attacks
by the feminists so I changed its name
to self-defeating personality disorder
and stuck it in the appendix which if I
had to get a graveyard event for the
filters I should say you know I'm a
terrible liberal and you know I'm not
starting all RD Laing suddenly but I
always see both sides of it you know and
and and I I do believe that there are
some disorders where a label it is only
a good thing and what I would say is is
OCD because you know you've got your
kids you've got OCD you a mess you've
got these intrusive thoughts you know
you're being haunted and you you know
there are kids everywhere right now who
are
thinking to themselves oh my god I'm
holding this glass I could load this
glass at you just thought we'll just pop
into their heads this does make me a
terrible person
you tell the human being I'm a good I
could I can yell out something racist
that I must be I must be terrible and
they get haunted by this and they go and
see a psychiatrist eventually and the
psychiatrist would say everybody has
these thoughts this does not make you a
bad person
it's just passively mad a theory sort of
pop into your head and then they pop out
again and it doesn't make you a terrible
person
and then a lot of people are killed by
that realization you know that the that
it's okay it's normal and so so it's the
Blizzard log and it's called OCD and
here are the ways that you can help it
can help you know in my new book so
you've been publicly shamed I talked
about how social media in the early days
was kind of like that people would
nervously admit his ACLU's shameful
secrets about themselves on social media
and other people would tweet back oh my
god I'm exactly the same and it was that
was kind of radical D shaming place and
that's I loved it it was incredible it
felt like a kind of Garden of Eden it
felt important you know that voiceless
people suddenly had a voice are one of
the things that was happening was that
we were we were punching up once the
Bella phrase you know we would we would
attack somebody who wrote you know who
would publish like a racist
column in a newspaper but also we were
people helping each other people being
unselfconscious and helping each other
like oh my god I had this kind of
terrible horrific idea that I could
throw this glass it's okay I'm exactly
the same this is like healing this was
even a phrase back then Facebook is
where you lie to your friends Twitter is
where you tell the truth to strangers
and then it just blew up in our faces
because people got so drunk with their
you know with wanting to do good with
wanting to be a good social justice
person
it just inverted and instead of people
openly and unselfconsciously admitting
hibbity shameful secrets suddenly people
were being defined and destroyed by
their shameful secrets you know and
that's the reason why I felt so
compelled almost if I could get a sequel
it away to a psychopath test - - right
so you've been publicly shamed because
you know to see us turn this wonderful
thing into this cold you know
surveillance culture with justice
heartbreaking they're selling author Jon
Ronson is our guest on in depth this
month on book TV and we often asks we
often ask the guests who come on some of
their influences what they're reading in
some of the favorite books here's what
Jon Ronson told us
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
presidential candidates often release
books to introduce themselves to voters
here's a look at some recent books
written by declared and potential
candidates for president former
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton looks
back on her time serving in the Obama
administration in hard choices in
American Dreams Florida Senator Marco
Rubio outlines his plan to restore
economic opportunity former Arkansas
governor Mike Huckabee gives his take on
politics and culture in God Guns grits
and gravy and in blue-collar
conservatives potential presidential
candidate Rick Santorum argues the
Republican Party must focus on the
working class in order to retake the
White House in a fighting chance
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
recounts the events in her life that
shaped her career as an educator and
politician wisconsin Governor Scott
Walker argues Republicans must offer
bold solutions to fix the country and
have the courage to implement them in
unintimidated and Kentucky Senator Rand
Paul who recently declared his candidacy
calls for smaller government and more
bipartisanship in taking a stand more
potential presidential candidates with
recent books include former Governor Jeb
Bush in immigration wars he along with
Clint Bolick argue for new immigration
policies in stand for something
Ohio Governor John Kasich calls for a
return to traditional American values
former Virginia Senator James Webb looks
back on his time serving in the military
and in the Senate in I heard my country
calling independent Vermont senator
Bernie Sanders recently announced his
intention to seek the Democratic
nomination for president his book the
speech is a printing of his eight
hour-long filibuster against tax cuts
and in promises to keep Vice President
Joe Biden looks back on his career in
politics and explains his guiding
principles neurosurgeon ben Carson calls
for greater individual responsibility to
preserve America's future in one
in fed-up former Texas Governor Rick
Perry explains government has become too
intrusive and must get out of the way
another politician who has expressed
interest in running for president is
former Rhode Island governor lincoln
Chafee in against the tide he recounts
his time serving as a Republican in the
Senate Carly Fiorina former CEO of
Hewlett Packard shares lessons she's
learned from her difficulties and
triumphs in rising to the challenge
Louisiana Governor Bobby Jindal
criticizes the Obama administration and
explains why conservative solutions are
needed in Washington in leadership and
crisis and finally in a time for truth
another declared presidential candidate
Texas senator Ted Cruz recounts his
journey from a Cuban immigrant son to
the US Senate look for his book in June
202 area code if you want to talk with
best-selling author Jon Ronson his most
recent book is so you've been publicly
shamed 7 for 8 8200 for those of you in
the eastern central time zone seven four
eight eight two zero one for those of
you in the mountain and Pacific this is
book TVs in-depth program three hours
with one author every month by the way
next month
Lawrence Wright will be our guest will
be out at the Chicago printers ro lick
fest and he will be our guest in Chicago
we'll be talking with the audience there
as well and he's written some he's
written a book on Scientology and has a
toxic documentary out on that issue that
the men who stare at goats were you
happy with the movie did you have any
say-so over how the movie came out I
didn't have any say-so but I was happy
with that in fact I watched it again
with Peter stone who I wrote who wrote
the screenplay about a year ago I was
creating a film festival in England and
so weary watched it kind of for the
first time as viewers really because
it's been so long and we kind of loved
it and it's got a few problems in the
last act I think the last that gets a
little bit complicated and long-winded
but that's what other than that I think
it's great and it was a nice experience
they were you know George Clooney was
lovely and very charming he's one of the
super famous people who is they kind of
considerate that the gotham undo cough
sweets i thought that seems random but
that's a specific thing and yeah I liked
it where did you find general
Stubblebine how did you make up that
name it was okay so what happened was
after my book Glenn came out I I made a
sale ease to go with them called secret
rulers of the world and it was like a
big hit and and then once it was in the
world is like my first ever hit in
Britain on BBC Alpha channel 4 and
channel 4 said this is great mixer more
and it's like here's the money
make more is money
I was like I'm I don't know what to do
this money and my producer Fenton said
you know don't tell him that
take a buddy and make something it never
happens you never just get money summers
okay but I'm not sure this is going well
yeah I think it's like a danger when
you've had a hit to just boom or you
know you know that's where failure lies
and indeed it's where failure lay
because we took the money and tried to
do more with no idea what we were going
so we wasted this huge amount of money
channa try to do the skullenbones story
at Yale and I just felt kind of dread I
thought you know what it's a student
club I'm like a man in my thirties going
off because to war you know it's like a
Steve student did I a so kind of balance
you know I mean um and then we tried to
try to do the story about how Bush's
grandfather the Prescott Bush had
possibly Grave logged Geronimo's grave
and stolen his skull so is that eight is
trying to do that story got nowhere and
then and then we're like flailing around
and then my producer at the time John
surgeon said to me what should we do
remote viewing and what had happened was
that this book had just come out called
remote viewers by an uncle Jim Schnabel
and it was uncovering the fact that the
CIA had this secret psychic spying
program of these funny and it looked
quite a serious book about this psychic
spies and of course when this stuff came
out in the mid nineties people like whoa
what we had like a team of psychic spies
right larathen to the mid 90s as crazy
as the Johnsons were left in the psychic
spy story no sir I'm not sure dim
snapples done it and you know boo gotta
do something
so we end up with this guy in Las Vegas
called Ray Hyman and he was a
psychologist who had been employed by
the CIA to assess
the psychic spying unit and he was a
skeptic and so I was interviewing him
but he was faced funny and sweet and I
was asking him about you know assessing
this unit and I didn't know where it was
going and yeah and I was you know
panicking and waking up in mid of the
night spending all of Channel Four's
money and and then I said to him this is
honestly you know a few times in your
life you'll just ask one question that
would like change your life and I and
this happened at this meeting with Ray
Hyman and I just said to him you know
when you were inside the CIA assessing
the psychic spies did you notice
anything else going on that was anything
else weird going on I just kind of eyes
twinkled and he said yeah he said there
was a guy called Stubblebine Major
General called Stubblebine who thought
that he could burst clouds just by
pointing at this as I said it was
another guy called Chaman who was
claiming his soldiers he's like
Lieutenant Colonel Channon
who was training all the soldiers to eat
only nuts and grains like for a month
I said bye Cartman Burlington house so
at the end of the interview I said to
John you know we've gotta find double
bond in Challon this could be our story
so in the search for stubble down in
Chanin we uncovered the whole many stare
at goats saga which was basically our
big breakthrough was in Hawaii the day
before Lynette Chanin I met this guy
called Glenn Wheaton um who was part of
this he was kind of who George Clooney's
based on in the movie oh they're just
lines based on a few people like a
composite and and he said he was part of
a secret military unit called project
Jedi and I said what was project says
and he said it was a series of levels
and I said what was level 1 it's at
level one was observation you walk in a
room how many chairs are in the room the
super-soldier
would just know so I said to have what
was level two hey so as level two with
intuition
you've got the fork in the road you go
left you go right
you'd go right so I said what was level
three is a level three with invisibility
so I said I said that's quite a leap
from level two I said what um actual
invisibility and he said at first but
after a while we just said after a while
we were just we adapted it to try and
find a way I'm not being seen
so I said like can flash you know and if
at level four was we had a master
sergeant that could stop the heart of a
goat I said what if I wanted just a
wanting him to stop and I said to be
ever manage it at his own once but his
heart got damaged in the process and I
said what was the goat
psychically fighting back and he said
said the golden standard turns
he said it's what's known in paranormal
circles as sympathetic injury and it's
at one time we had room with 30 goats in
the room and we all stand up got number
16 and governmentís 17 fell over which I
guess his collateral damage and so I
went back to London I was watching the
tape and my wife came in from a party I
was a doula you've gotta watch it I just
watch the Ergo see so he could have corn
at the many stare at goats and I said
yes that's why we called it mr. agos and
then I met stubble bird general
Stubblebine
and his thing and it is how the movie
starts was out he with he thought that
because the human body is made up mostly
of a thermos and the action is made up
mostly of space and the wall is made
mostly of Athens that means it's
possible to merge the spaces so he would
get up from behind his desk this is
Major General Albert Stubblebine the
third head of Army Intelligence and run
then blasts into the hall but he never
lasted it never mastered it ah he said
one time though he did bruise his nose
but he was going through a messy divorce
at the time so his colleagues thought it
might have just been too
- Kabir so yeah that's how I'm a double
guarded Shannon and I think for me
weirdly
but the moment when I thought this could
be a book was the realization it's
double bad and Shannon and Glenn Wheaton
and these other people all knew each
other and I said well while I could
write a can of almost like the kind of
soap opera about this bubble and then
what I discovered was that some of the
people involved and he's in these things
back in the 70s were also involved in
Guantanamo Bay and Abu Ghraib and it's a
very very crooked path but there was a
path and so the second half of the
Minnesota Coast there's a kind of more
serious explanation of how these kind of
hippie ideas from the seventies mutated
into something darker it in turn the war
on terror and in fact you you are either
quote or interview Lindsey England
saying that what happened in Abu Ghraib
where she's holding this prisoner on
release was a military intelligence yeah
I wonder whether I'm not really
addressed anymore with her interest
greater than what they say now but yeah
at the time that is what they were
saying that this was high up you know
this wasn't just this wasn't just you
know random acts of cruelty that they
came up with by themselves but it was it
was you know for a greater good that
they were told to do this stuff I sigh
up as like a cadiz and can I just draw a
parallel again with so you've been
publicly shamed by the way because I
remember the be one of the one of the
big non-lethal people a guy called Sid
Hale said to me that the holy grail of
lat interrogation techniques inside
Guantanamo and above-grade is called the
book or effect and to cut a long story
short the Buca effect is let's imagine
it's late at night and you're walking
down a corridor and a figure jumped out
in front of you nice scream
and then you realize it's your wife he
said that's two parts of your brain
working at different speeds and it's to
do with the amygdala and he said the
Bucher effect is is they're together for
like interrogators to hold on to that
moment of being like
absolutely stars hold that before you
realize it see wives that moment of our
Pinker debilitatingly startled and if
you can hold on to that moment maybe
through flashing lights blasting music
you know if it's true what lyndie
england says he likes i offered these
pictures you know just blablabla order
that then you you've you've accomplished
the boot cool effects I was thinking
about the Booker effect when I was uh I
was thinking about the blue cool effect
when I was writing them so big gotta be
shamed because I just in sucka was
asleep on the plane hundreds of
thousands of people were tweeting I
can't wait till her plane lands and she
signs out what's been going on oh man
everybody in this bar is so into hash
tag has just been landed yet can't look
away you know there were there were
hundreds of thousands people maybe
millions of people waiting but just in
faculty land and I thought oh my god you
know while Justin Sacher slept on the
plane Twitter I discovered the pleasures
of the blue Crescent Bob in Tahlequah
Oklahoma
you're on with author Jon Ronson yeah
it's good good to have access here
listening to you the other day I found a
lot of what you're talking about with
social media to be quite interesting
aiya I struggle a lot with I'm in my 50s
I struggle a lot with with social media
the value of it whether it is valuable
or not I think it is I think it's a
jaded situation that kind of bears the
soul of the society the collective
society at the same time in for averages
so and I wanted to run something by you
I do a lot of writing about false
paradigms of power that are propped up
and held up and continued right to
extinction I'm writing about this I I
describe our society as it presently
exists and I'd like to get a little
feedback from you on this
here on the phone I don't have my TV on
so what I'm seeing is a society that
essentially is going a lot like it's a
fear wagon and it's loaded onto and it's
unloaded on to constantly but it's never
emptied out so it never has a potential
to heal and it never arrives anywhere
and it never remains anywhere so the
culture is in question constantly and
this creates a great deal of anxiety
which you speak of quite eloquently I so
enjoy the detail with which you examine
things going on here
I appreciate you also want to say this
we're going to we're going to have to
get an answer from our guests right and
if you're going to listen to the phone
I'll leave you on and while you're
listening well if you if you write as
well as you speak I'll be back
beautifully because some of the faces
you just used if it were just beautiful
and and yet when you talked about the
fear wagon I mean you know we know that
politics and the mainstream media trade
in fear and has you know has been
throughout modern history mobile phone
Adam Curtis calls the power of
nightmares we you know we we trade in
these in terrors we make money out of
terror and the way that's mutated on
social media is fear has become like
outrage and so now if somebody
transgresses if we determine that
somebody is outside of our acceptable
norms our social circle our mutual
approval machine we are outraged and of
course what all of this is doing is
creating a much more conformist and
conservative Wilden and I was giving her
giving a talk in London quite recently
somebody came up to me in the signing
key last words and said that she was a
child ferret
and he said pretty much every child who
comes to her damaged now is damaged this
is something that happened on social
media because of this this outrage
machine now that everybody's getting
defined I think it really is it's a
cousin you know when you talk about
people peddling fear you know you're
talking about you know we're gonna dive
with a little bit us on art you know the
war on terror the caves
you know bin Laden's system of high-tech
caves in Afghanistan you know over and
over again it's like you know the
spreading of fear for you know various
you know but you know the close cousin
of that is is is outraged on social
media that's the same thing is all about
dehumanizing people it's all about
labeling rejecting demonizing people
it's all about pretending that
somebody's badly worded tweet is a clue
to their inherent evil you know it's
just it's this you know erroneous
understanding about how human beings
actually work and how can the bigs
actually work that we were kind of a mix
of talents and flaws and wisdom and
stupidity and for yeah forget what you
notice on social media so you know we
have the opportunity to do something new
and wonderful but we are you know
repeating the mistakes of these systems
that were trying to better
is there a bullying aspect all of this
yeah there is a bullying aspect I mean
well I come very much from social
justice world and I think you know I'm a
humanist but my stories are all about
trying to pick up the people who've been
wronged and sometimes they're they're
the people who've been wronged are kind
of unfashionable wrongs people like
Justine Sacco or the Weaver family it'll
tell you some good more than the
psychopath test you know I'm sticking up
for wronged you know wronged people
whoever people don't stick up for just
because I think you know a wrongs person
is along to person but I come very much
from the social justice world and I
always have but you know what seems to
be happening now is that there's a kind
of extreme end of the social justice
world who is so passionate and outspoken
that they're kind of
because I quite know they're kind of
kind of winning and it's like it's like
if you're not as radical as we are and
as ideological as we are then you're
part of the problem and that feels can
be a bit like bullying Paula tweets in
your genius is born from curiosity and
goes on to ask what does mr. Ronson see
as the biggest ideological differences
between Britain and America hmm um I've
been living in America for three years
now so I should have some good answers
for that
um one once thought I think one slightly
negative thing of no distance since
they'd be publicly shamed has come out
is even though sort of ingrained in the
American culture is the idea of
redemption and second chances and you
know we'll all floor do we all make
mistakes I think some some American
people in a bit too but you know the
American justice system and also some
Americans don't really feel that way you
know they don't really feel that people
should have second chances and they a
big there's a color to Kody anism
injustice amongst some Americans that
personally I wish wasn't there I want to
live in the world where transgressions
are put within a wider human context and
I want to live in the world of people
get second chances so that's one
difference I've noted but to balance
that out with something more positive
and because I'd be living here three
years and I I'm am I love it here and I
feel it's becoming my home I think
America is very can-do and if it's
unforgiving about transgressions
it's very open to giving people a chance
they open to thirst chances are quite
closer to second chances you know in
Britain if you want to do like a car
though like if I wanted to do a comedy
club in London I'd go to me soon some
people go I'm not sure you should do
that you know if I want to do a comedy
club in Brooklyn I'm doing one within a
month which is what I am doing with my
friend May Pickens and and that's
something that feels very American
Jeffery and Fort Lauderdale good
afternoon to you all good afternoon John
it's a real treat having you on the show
I loved your TED talk on the psychopathy
test and in particular when you
mentioned the gray areas and that's
where you manatee is and and I mental
health professional I've been in the
field for 30 years and I'd like to make
a brief comment and then just listen to
what if anything you have to say to that
the Diagnostic and Statistical Manual of
Mental Disorders the so-called Bible I
am a critic of the DSM because lacks
scientific validity now I think you and
I would agree there is mental illness
but the diagnosis in the DSM are not
objective medical conditions like
diabetes or heart disease which are
diagnoseable through mental to objective
tests they're they're basically symptoms
and behaviors that are observed by a
clinician and they amount to myths that
are based on socially constructed norms
that you spoke of and the problem and
here's the end of my comment the problem
is labeling people based on these myths
these labels preclude clinicians from
addressing the gray areas that you spoke
so eloquently
in your TED talk alright let's leave it
there connect oh I'm so sorry I hung up
on it okay cuz I was still asking the
question si what if he could come back
I met it's going to be impossible but
well rested up Jeffrey if you're hearing
now why don't you try to phone back and
and what was your question well my
question was going to be you know this
is you know serious question I had
looking at the answer's no mental health
professional you know there's 400 or so
mental disorders in the dsm does he feel
that way about every one of them or does
he think that some test lists and some
disorders in the DSM have got it
absolutely right that's a genuine
question because you're mad because you
know I come from world of gray areas and
so to me I'm thinking okay some of these
disorders in the DSM are baffling and
I'm ridiculous but there are others you
know they seem right to me
so I've said the villian system is with
you or not well if he calls back in we
will we will get him back on the line so
you can ask him that question Samantha
and El Paso thanks for holding your own
with Jon Ronson hi I'm excited to talk
to you love your work and thanks to
c-span for great programs like this I
was just wondering how long from the
idea to do something when it strikes you
to completion does it take with research
and everything to complete a project and
you just work on one at a time or do you
have several different things going on
at once and does it take a while between
projects too because it seems like
you're so into which of whatever you're
working on whatever book or topic and
does it take a while afterwards to kind
of get that out of your system or how
does that process work Donna thank you
it's always long the answer to every
question ethically long it takes me it
takes me forever to to come up with a
subject and it takes me forever to write
it and then I Whittle and whistle and
Whittle it down because I for some
reason post me sue is leaving not to go
into a diagnosis myself abuzz with you
leaving a little get ADHD
III really I'm always really nervous
about boring people so if I find a kind
of superfluous word in a sentence I will
I will strike it out and and so which is
what my books contain me three years of
like constant obsessive work yet you can
read them in a day and a half for that
reason and then yeah you get it fast
forever until I mean the psychopathy
test in particular like I talked about
that book like like you know took me to
you two half years to write and I talked
about it non-stop for like two years and
I was really kind of yearning for a day
what I'd be giving a talk on stage and I
was bored I wanted to I wanted to become
bored with the topic so I could get it
out of my system and and and write
something new and so really that's what
me that took me forever it does it takes
me forever because and I don't have
another book yeah
luckily I'm writing a movie with it with
the great South Korean collector from
joon-ho some that new movie with him at
the moment so it works for traffic i
Lance forbidden and submit ins and
sayings and submit and launching a
question but it's good well what about
the fact that the psychopathy test was
being made into a movie correct yeah I
mean we think there's many a slip twixt
cup and delet which is why I actually
put some Thai tears myself a few minutes
ago but yes Kristen Gore who worked on
Foxcatcher and the brilliant writer is
writing the screenplay jwilks is
collecting whose it will know is a
brilliant bill in traffic does
everything some kind of broad comedy
like Meet the Parents through to like
incredible political dramas like Game
Change and Scarlett Johansson is set to
scale notes but beyond that what raw and
beyond that compiled no idea you know
what I've noticed over the years like
from the men estate goats to flank which
is a movie that I co-wrote with
Shawn which God made with Michael
Fassbender and and this that if you had
the provider of the source material stay
the hell out because you know the screen
record does not want ears leaning over
their shoulder and nor should you do
that you know it's been it's the relay
race and you've given the baton over and
just stay the hell out and so far as I
know at dinner with Kristen and Jay
Roach a Christmas
I haven't spoken since I deliberately
just fun to let them get on with it I
did what the films going to be I know
it's going to be fictionalized and same
way that many stare at goats was and
they say where the Frank was people tend
to like my work
I don't offer like obvious movie
narratives in my books but what I do
offer is like great dialogue gray momen
and comedy a different way of seeing the
world and then I think a really great
screen as you can fix all that together
into a new narrative so I think that's
love Kristen's doing
we have Geoffrey back on the line from
Fort Lauderdale Geoffrey Jon Ronson had
a question for you
hijacker didn't people did you hear the
question we'll go ahead and repeat it oh
but other people we stated to the viewer
yes absolutely so you were saying that
your mental health professional and you
said you're very skeptical of me the DSM
the mandelip mental disorders and my
question is really quite simple so you
know other kind of terrible gray area
liberal my view has always been okay
some of the disorders in the DSM are
clearly you know absurd and ridiculous
within others you assume are they've got
it routes that the checklist is you know
the scientific way of of identifying
that particular mental illness or mental
disorder so my question to you was you
know you sort of suspicious of the DSM
in its entirety or do you how do you
think okay no that one's okay that one's
not and so on but it's an excellent
question and I appreciate you you aim in
general in your work to strike balance
my short answer is yes and no
yes I think all the diagnoses in the DSM
lacks scientific validity why because
they they lack objective criteria
because there's no objective test that
can accurately make the diagnosis
however but no I don't discount all the
diagnoses and and agree with you because
there there is such a thing as severe
mental illness such as psychosis and
mood disorders however and we need some
basis at - to diagnose and the DSM is
the only game in town the National
Institute of Mental Health however is
doing the right thing the research to
actually identify the brain anomalies
associated with mental disorder one last
point John there are some disorders that
are so ridiculous such as adjustment
disorder or oppositional defiant
disorder which basically childhood can I
can I just tell you my oppositional
defiant disorder story I know a little
girl who was diagnosed with OCD and
didn't get over the OCD after her run of
cognitive behavioral therapy so the
cognitive behavioral therapist then
diagnosed the girl is having
oppositional defiant disorder oh okay
because I I thought you said OCD I am
and I was in a correct you'll and say I
was referring to old DJ no no no this
little girl got an OCD diagnosis but
then when CBT didn't didn't get her
through it within the kind of requisite
period the therapist gave her an
additional diagnosis of OBD so I think
you and I are basically on the same page
but I would just close by saying the DSM
is the only game in town for doing
diagnosis but none of the none of the
none of the diagnoses are valid and the
National Institute of
so health is into the long game to
actually identify the objective brain
anomalies that correspond to mental
disorders but this is the best the best
show on TV right now to have you such a
pleasure and and that TED talk is so
inspiring and just so well done I really
appreciate all right gentlemen were you
at this time we are going to hang up and
not call you back
thank you gesture that's that's really
good the other ridiculous one in the DSM
you know they got rid of childhood
bipolar disorder because you know little
kids were being diagnosed with bipolar
you know the age of like 2 and 3 because
they had temper tantrums so in the new
DSM dsm-5 they made like an effort to
move away from that but they came up
with a new disorder called disruptive
mood dysregulation disorder which you
know which is kind of what it sounds
like it's like you know a teenager or
child you know having having big mood
swings
you know that's now a disorder TIMSS
true on our Facebook page and by the way
if you can't get through on the phone
lines and want to make a comment you
could try our social media addresses
will flash those up on the screen
Tim's troop posts on public shaming on
social media whatever happened to the
development of what used to be called
building a thick skin to other people's
comments when I was young I was taught
to ignore stupid and mean comments I
understand the public nature of social
media makes it more serious but people
react too strongly to what others say on
social media don't feed the trolls you
know I mean I understand that and but
the problem is when somebody's at the
end of like a big shaming somebody like
Justine Sacco a whole bunch of things
happen firstly you get fired because the
many companies were like whoa you know
if we don't get rid of this person it's
going to be us next you know scared of
the bullies right so if you get 5 - you
lose your livelihood worse than that I
would say and I can say this because I
have met people in this situation
young woman could Lindsay stout lovely
woman comes to Washington DC
it works with adults with learning
difficulties so she's bringing them on
earth on a tour to do say there's all
the things I did yesterday ago and CD
the Lincoln Memorial and you know that
was Washington Monument immense up in
Arlington at the Tomb of the Unknown
Soldier so Lindsey great employee lovely
young woman has is kind of running joke
with her friends where they pose in
front of a sign and do the opposite of
the side so they smoke in front of a
non-smoking sign or loiter in front of a
no loitering sign just got a deuce
teacher command post it on Facebook
anyway Arlington they see a sign that
says keep off the grass so things should
worry Megan old or against rebel their
little another sign that says silence
and respect
so they inspiration strikes so Lindsey
poses respond to the side and we're
showing that picture on the Erin so
pretending to shout and flippant English
the joke another sign post it on
Facebook a couple of like military
friends saying you know I know you girls
but you know that's kind of offensive
and sidon legit all of the ridiculous
just a spring douches forget about it to
kind of fine and then Lindsay says to
have fun should we take it down
no Jamie - first Olympics we take it
down and Lindsay says now are we in
ridiculous you lived a bit of a think
about it again a month later they're in
a restaurant and suddenly the phone
start going crazy and it's gone viral
it's gone all over the place what
Lindsay did that night with go home no
this is a completely
unequipped young woman is suddenly being
told by tens of thousands of people that
she's a monster
you know there's everything from like
outrageous trolls like we're going to
rape you with a video on social media
and over the telephone they got hold of
a home number
right foods like concerns nice people
which are the ways like worse you know
we're disappointed in you you're a bad
person
you disrespect the military you know yo
tell you know and so on Lindsey was up
all night reading every single comment
about her she was fired from her job so
for months and months and months she
would just read every comment and those
comments just snaked their way into her
you know mangled up her mental health
you know depression insomnia anxiety
they basically didn't leave home for a
year and a half
what what what kind of boss her back I
wrote to her three times and said I want
to tell your story in my book and
finally I I you know convinced her to
talk to him and now anybody thing like
incredibly nice to Lindsay and it's
what's brought it back in because you
know though is it is deeply until it's
happen to on that kind of scale it's
impossible to know what it feels like
it's terrible it can it can ruin
people's mental health you know to be
cast out as a social creature to be cast
out is it's horrific and what cures it
what kills it is to be brought back in
with compassion and kindness and empathy
Lou era White Plains New York hi Lana hi
how are you thank you John for your
chronicling of the social media
situation I have a question I'd like to
take it back to Justine I believe
because to me that's kind of like the
essence of some of what I'm hearing
about all of the wonderful things you've
said in these personality types and
whether they've been diagnosed or not
but here's my thought why is it that
most of what you have mentioned coming
off of this Twitter shaming that was
done to her
it seems to me comes up as an approach
from a human communication perspective
that only involves ranting and raving
it's kind of like what I call upper case
in your face
verbal slaps that are in my way of
thinking shut the other person
that's number one it's very unlikely the
Justine is going to respond to a barrage
and I realize that twitter has a minimum
number of things you could say but why
is it that you think most of and if this
is not the case please you know help me
out here
why is it that's the way it went rather
than as I think many people you know
were trained to think about is a more
reasoned a question kind of normal
verbal words you know that would
facilitate a sense that both sides of
being heard in other words the shaming
thing as opposed to I would say okay
Justine and I know you can't do this on
Twitter Justine let's talk about what
you thought you were saying and whether
or not you stepped back to to realize
that's all rain the weather was going to
leave it there jon ronson well yeah
because I'll be what Loretta is
describing those democracy people listen
to each other and they may disagree and
they and they argue and they listen
that's how things that's how human
communication should be but what happens
on social media is the opposite of
democracy you surround yourself with
people and you know tech utopians call
social media new types of democracy what
is what is greater is is organizing this
greater organization it's good at
organizing protests and so on but it's
not democratic because what happens is
you surround yourself with people to
feel the same way you do that's how
social media is set up and when things
are going well that's great you know I
tell a joke and lots of people tell me
how great I am and still oh it's great
and also you find people in the ether
you'll have a similar point of view to
you but then what happens is that you're
locked up in this bubble this kind of
echo chamber this kind of mutual
approval machine and you don't want to
hear
the sale even poseable I repeat it like
a woman called Helen Louis a reviewer
who reviewed my book feminist writer in
England she wrote on the night of Justin
Sacher shaming I don't think Justin was
intending to be racist at a whole bunch
people said you know you're just a
privileged [ __ ] to and like and that's
like all you know get out get out of our
network you know that's that screaming
somebody out there is not democratic you
know to destabilise that good feeling
that mutual approval is is bad people
don't like it so they throw you out so
people don't want to hear you know
injustice you hear what the person has
to say right in court you hear what the
person has to say if they want to say it
justine sacco the such an important
moment i think in the development of
this new media past me partly because
she was asleep on a plane and oblivious
to her destruction and that became part
of the joy of it you know part of the
joy of it was we're about to watch this
justine sacco [ __ ] gets fired in real
time before she even knows she's getting
fired at another point in my book I
wrote about a disgraced pop science also
called jonah lehrer who committed some
journalistic sins and lost his job
rightly but then this moment happened
later when I was spending time with
Jonah for the book where he was given an
opportunity to publicly apologize for
what he did at a foundation called the
knight Foundation and he had an Knight
Ridder right yes he sent me a speech and
you know I don't know what to make of it
because it seemed like he was them it
seemed like a jonah lehrer it was that
kind of pop neuroscience apology speech
so yeah barely
so Jonah turns up at the foundation and
he knew that they were get a live stream
his apology but what they didn't know
was they had erected a giant screen
Twitter feed giant screen right next to
Jonah's head with another monitor image
I line the world Jonah was trying to
apologize he could read what piece
were tweeted in real-time real-time
responses for his quest for forgiveness
and another chance so as he's trying to
apologize the tweets that were coming up
in huge letters were jonah lehrer boring
us and chris forgiving him jonah lehrer
is just a frigging sociopath you see
there's that that word again you know we
want to destroy somebody but we don't to
feel bad about it so we demonize them
winner with over the word like sociopath
jonah lehrer has not proven he is
capable of feeling shame you know this
barrage as he's trying to apologize how
imagine if that was an actual court and
the murderer was standing up in the dock
trying to explain their circumstances
and the jewelry are yelling out bald
sociopath you know if we were watching a
Courtland drama at the cinema and that
scene happened we wouldn't think that
was good yet you give us power you know
you you put the power in our hands and
that's how we abuse it
you know we become even though we're on
this you know when we watch the
Courtland job it's good we like we like
Atticus Finch give us the power we
become like the hanging judges we become
the people in the lists the graphs being
rivaled at whippings and why the reason
why is because we are and I include
myself in this we have social justice
people that we water we want to punch up
water attack people who misuse their
privilege but while jonah lehrer was
desperately trying to apologize in front
of that screen after being disgraced and
ruined and out of work for ten months
that wasn't privileged that was somebody
on the floor
we felt we were punching up but actually
we were kicking someone when they were
down our politicians legitimate targets
for public shaming
representative aaron schock who had to
resign recently because yeah it is
office up like Downton Abbey and some
other things came up yeah I said
certainly I mean when I was writing so
he'd been publicly shamed that I felt
most comfortable writing my people at
Justine Sacco and Lindsey stone like
ordinary people who were being
disproportionately punished for some
tiny transgression and I thought you
know I thought I had to draw that line
because it would be ridiculous for me to
write a book where suddenly I was saying
I am against
I'm against you know criticizing any
kind of transgression you know I'm not
against satire I'm not against
journalism I'm not against investigative
journalism I'm not against curiosity I'm
not against holding powerful people to
account you know this book isn't against
any of those things what this book is
against is our new widespread forest
fire proclivity to ruin people ordinary
people for nothing next call for Jon
Ronson comes from David and Portland
Oregon hi David hi I was just wondering
what your favorite visual and performing
artists are and I particularly get sort
of a Robyn Hitchcock vibe from you
ah yes possibly it why do you ask that
question babe I'm just curious I'm
always a little curious what people what
meat music and bar people and is and I
just sort of get a feeling that you
probably read me probably likes to me
yeah I got good music to you is Bluff
squeeze it was some sort of soul and
depth to it I don't know that's a tough
question a big letter thank you sir
thank you I'm a I listen to a lot kind
of English post-punk having a something
I go through most of all so I listen to
The Fool every day every day I listen to
the fall the fall so great and so so
criminally unknown in this country so I
listen to the fall
I've worked recently I've been working
with the Scottish band Belle and
Sebastian and they'd they scored a short
film that I made with Matthew Perry I
made a silent comedy with Matthew Perry
called the dog fella and belen Sebastian
did the score for that I listened to
them a lot I always thought I once made
a documentary about Randy Newman and I
said in it that every thought I had ever
had has already been asked regarding
Eamon I do think the Randy Newman is
like my sort of thought process
doppelganger
uh so him very much
yeah this is the first big clue in
tonight well what about this gentleman
they were going to show on screen now
Frank Sidebottom do you listen to him I
was in his band
I was blanks keyboard player and in the
in the late 80s when I left Curtis and
moved to London I became the I became
the entertainments officer from a local
college the Polytechnic of central
London and one day the phone rang and
this voice said Frank suppose we played
tonight but our keyboard players had we
can't make it so we're gonna have to
cancel unless you know the keyboard
players so I said I play keyboards and
he said well you're in heard but I don't
know any of your songs and he said can
you play C F and G and just luckily
those are the three notes I could play I
said yes there were UN so I joined
Frank's band for three years and I was
he was amazing and he was just kind of
avant-garde calm but he always wore this
big fake heads that he never took us and
believe me nothing makes a young man
feel more alive and on an adventure than
cruising up the motorway at two o'clock
in the morning sitting next to a man
wearing a big fake head so I'd look and
or I'd wonder why he kept the head on
for like way longer than he had so he
would have served us in the van
sometimes he kept the head on so we we
would play these venues of like 500
people 750 people one time Frank was
booked to play Wembley supported his boy
band called brough it was like the one
direction of the time a little to choke
this is as big as this 50,000 people
this was his biggest audience ever by 49
thousand five hundred people and but he
chose to just do a series of terrible
broth cover versions with his head on it
always sing like app and I've got
bottles off stage after about 10 minutes
and one gig we played with at JB's
nightclub in Dudley in the West Midlands
and public theories of the word Dudley
has ever been on c-span and there were
hardly anybody in the audience and 20
people in the audience and halfway
through the show the audience ignoring
us split up into two teams and we got
out of football and played again and we
got offstage and study flag took off his
head and was crystal and underneath the
do name is Chris and he said dad best
show we have a place I then then he
fired at all for tax reasons he got into
terrible taxable and
and then 15 years passed and then I was
in the park with my with my son Joel and
my phone rang and his voice said hello
and I said Frank and if at all yes I
said how are you I am at subside Billy
put Chris on here at IHOP if I could go
along the line and said hello Tom and he
said he was going to say to come back
and could i I thought could I reach on
the band's like I'd seen the Blues
Brothers and he was going to happen he
said no no I want you to write something
about our time in the band so I wrote
this little piece in The Guardian and it
really came out emotional really came
out a bit mid life crisis II heard it I
was like you know writing about that
moment when I got up on stage with him
for the first time and being in this
crazy band with this guide it was very
emotional and and after after I wrote
the piece my friend Peter strong who
wrote a screenplay for the minister at
goats which given my broken and also
more recently wrote screenplays for Wolf
Hall which has been amazing Hilary
Mantel's yeah Hilary Mantel's and book
Richard on PBS at the most wonderful
series and Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy
anyway he said to me and you know I've
always wanted to write a fake music
biopic
like what would happen if Captain
Beefheart's was alive in the 1950s and
then Peter said but your ideas better
and I said I have no idea what you're
talking about what idea I said a man
with a big fake head and I said that's
not my ideas actually happened he said
this is what happened it's a left like
that
so me and pacer for the next four five
years started writing a screenplay about
a fictional John Jordan a fictional band
led by a man who wears a big fake head
that he never takes us like our flag
would never take off his head and then
and it got made we got it made with I
think so I imagined our frank to be a
kind of mix of the real Frank and
Captain Beefheart's and Daniel Johnson
who's this incredibly talented bipolar
singer-songwriter early question about
which visual artists and musicians I
admire one of the things I admire more
than anything is the documentary about
Daniel Johnson and called the devil and
Daniel Johnson which I recommend to all
of your listeners get it from get it
and so we imagined our friend to be a
mix of all of these people and you know
completely out of the blue Michael
Fassbender said he wanted to play Frank
so we said are you is he definitely
aware that he was a big fake head for
the entire movie that he never takes off
so yes he's aware so got made got made
and it was a great thing unfortunately
Chris passed away while we were writing
the screenplay never got - never got to
see the movie you know I've been telling
stories because of my dog so you've been
publicly shamed about bad things that
have happened as a result of public meet
public and social media is something
good that happened and Chris died and
the day after his death he was announced
in the local paper and the Manchester
Evening is that he was going to be
buried in a pauper's grave and I sort of
what a hell is a pauper's grave you know
what we could we come back in time 200
years but it turned out there was such a
thing as a porpoise funeral if you died
penniless so I sent out one tweet and
said you know for a few thousand pounds
Chris could be spared a porpoise grave
and by the end of the day over a
thousand people had sent in about 23,000
pounds which was you know more than
enough to bury an exhuming reburying
half doesn't
so you know that's when we can get
together before the great good Robert
and Las Vegas emails in it's hysterical
that Brian Williams is being set up for
what the press has been doing for a very
very long hmm exaggeration and yeah yeah
the reason I am reluctant is because I
haven't liked like until the Grand
Williams scandal I never heard of Graham
Williams as a British person and so the
reason why I'm slightly reluctant to
weigh in on it if I don't quite
understand what Graham Williams means in
the American landscape like was he like
a really respected go to youth
commentator who traded on like absolute
either sincerity in factual accuracy
awarding more of a kind of showman and
you know so that's the reason why I tend
not to weigh in on the band Williams
thing because I don't got understand
what the name brand Williams brings with
it Marcus
Portland Oregon hi Marcus hey thanks
very much for taking my call John really
enjoying the conversation was actually
kind of amused at the beginning when you
kind of looks questioningly at Peter
that you could go on so yeah because
this is definitely this is the Madison
dance contest of this people to
interview at the end of the interview
I'm going to start solving and peeps
going to take the outside and kill me so
that's a boiler sufficient sources don't
marry publicize okay yeah well I didn't
want to go too much on more on the
social media bit and still I'm brought
back to it I'm a skimmer of your books
and it seems to me that that that in the
last decade or so that book by Nicholas
Carr called the shallows which I quite
like is that people know a lot about a
lot of different things but getting in
in depth which is why I like this show
is a struggle and I was wondering if
maybe you could speak a little bit to
that in terms of really getting in-depth
into a topic and then and then just as a
follow-up them can you just sort of
maybe
what you do to recharge after you've
gone in depth to a lot of different
things besides Peter I'm holding your
your sobbing girl thanks very much thank
you
yep for me when I really lose myself in
it in a story in a in a in a very real
way you know when we were on our way me
and Peter spoon we're on our way to
Toronto for the premiere of the many
spirit goats I was at halfway through
writing like a Stefan on the plane I
said to Peter I know how to spot
psychopath identical I know they rule
the world and I know exactly how to spot
them and I now have this power and Peter
looked to me like I was like I've gone
insane he was like water rocks you know
dirty ridiculous and and and I love
moments like that when I genuinely have
turned for one human being to another
human being and it happened in in them
when after I've been chased like a
people were listening all the way back
it you know hours ago I talked about
being chased by the Bilderberg Group and
how I became that really paranoid and
and started imagining myself being being
chased and then you totally lose
ourselves we kind of go crazy if agony
that's not pleasant and you're walking
around parks thinking how do I make
sense this is a such a method of his
contradictory thoughts are swirling
around my head and yeah oh my god you
know like the DSN with the psychopathy
test ago and my for the DSM against the
DSM is labeling good as labeling bad
deliah mentally ill people at their
decide time is just a crazy but they've
been moving they're not crazy about this
aspect of things but does that make me
you know and all of these thoughts wound
around I don't understand you know I am
and and it's painful and agony and you
know when I was out in the minister it
goes I hope that remember this quote and
now I started reciting the ministerial
girls oh I wish I could remember you
know what I may not be able to remember
it was a quote from a US Supreme Court
judge I would not give a big whatever
for simplicity this side of complexity
but I would give my life for simplicity
on the other side of complexity and
that's what I try and do in my books you
know you you lose yourself in all of
this stuff and you examine it from every
possible including the craziest aspects
you know and you drown in it all and
then you come out at the end with
something simple and yet all the
complexities in there but it's a fun
page turning read you know that's it so
I can't say it's fun to write but that's
what I'm aiming for and I'm gonna how do
I cuddle a recover
honestly lat half I take half a day off
and then I start to feel guilty and I
start working again Jon Ronson do you
read a lot of the reviews the critiques
of your books are you um know locust on
there now I tend to attempt to like skim
and if I see a word like delightful or
super out it
I think okay good so that I start
anything I bet if I skim and if I see a
word like false equivalencies but the
world I don't know that's not reading so
I have it so dismayed I got a vague idea
of whether it's supposed to be for the
negatives with you but then I don't read
further you know I did give a rule to
myself one day once about you know if
you read a good review like a great race
how happy are you you're happy for about
three seconds slow and then it all you
know really miserable again if you read
a bad review how unhappy I am you're
massively unhappy for ages so you hit a
guy I gave myself the rule of luck I'm
going to be exactly at unhappy by bad
criticism say I'm happy about good
criticism and and that worked for ages
and now we've so you've been publicly
shamed because there has been a couple
of back lashes again to the book which I
should say by the way I don't think
affair I think be one or two people have
said that I don't understand I don't
write about why women get it worse than
men in trainings
when in fact the book is entirely about
why women get a bliss and then insane
links so I decided if not read anything
with this book because I think it was
just annoying me because I think there's
some misrepresentation in my book out
there so so so I'm not reading anything
at all
Doug is up in Brookline Massachusetts
Doug you're on with Arthur Jon Ronson
and pop TV oh hello you produced a video
called escape and control and that which
didn't go down too well amongst members
of the Jewish community or some of them
at least could you were enlarge upon
that and are you by any chance a fan of
Max Blumenthal the author of Goliath
thanks a lot and make amends Russell um
what is escape and control yeah it's
great and control is a web series that I
did about about control on the internet
but I was a bit early to that thing
about Jewish community I did one episode
where I went to Israel and look food
assertively looking looked at how
certain you know stores Zionists were I
kind of remember it was it was it was
just it was a episode that wasn't that
gray and didn't really get any
controversy as far as I can remember
I don't think so the kind of nobody
really watched it I don't member really
bring anything there was a couple of
episodes about the series that were good
and were really watched including I
hooked up with Patrice Wolf's and the
you know he he's an LA producer and if
you're like a rich mother with a teenage
daughter he'll write a song and record a
video for you and you write in and tell
the truth will said like what your likes
and dislikes her and then Patrice black
$2,000 could she select record a video
for you and put it online and one of the
funds went kind of crazy viral I'm not
heard of much blue metallic glass bottle
myself of tanto slap so yeah what a
producer songs that really viral Rebecca
Black's Friday
remember there's like half a
thing was like Friday so he wrote this
some here at the sug about either Friday
like outside I got an embedded Friday
was good so so I wrote to Patrice it's
like a little silly thing I said you
know can you do one for me
a disable what are you likes and
dislikes and I whose thoughts about this
and Asia said well on on Tuesday
evenings I sometimes get to go to the
cinema by myself and it's nice you know
just have a couple of hours to myself I
go to the movies by myself and that's
probably my favorite thing and so he
gave that with this song that when I'm
getting older my life is over
that's bad so that one went Gathers
supervirus but nobody's answer I'm not
shirking the question I honestly don't
remember what it would good beans and
outs of what I did in Israel and I don't
remember really getting any criticism
for it your level of fame and in Great
Britain as opposed to here
can you walk down the street in Great
Britain I get recognized I get
recognized but not in any kind of I
remember really big star called Zoe ball
once said to me you've got it perfect
like you've got enough stage that make
your ego feel good but not so much like
you know you can't you can do anything
that you want so if I do like a talk and
Griffin I can talk like I could London
or Glasgow Manchester I could probably
give a talk and like a thousand people
show up I'll get that recognized few
times a week do you fill a box straw
here on your book tour
yeah but smaller we did a show in San
Francisco where about 600 people came
and then I did stores in like Nashville
and so on where maybe 100 hundred fifty
people claim and to cruise they saw that
that was nice for me to be able to turn
up in Santa Cruz and get hundred fifty
people feels like amazing Frank Bluff
City Kansas good afternoon
oh wow didn't you
hi Cassie oh wow because I'm in our
movie Frank with Michael Fassbender
Frank comes from blood cancer about just
a coincidence huh
but you know I'm interested in the
economics of all of this that you dealt
with when you've written but I haven't
heard it on the show today
one thing is like justine sacco got
fired because she was an economic
liability to her employer EF m3 is is
useful because it allows psychologists
and psychologists to to bill for their
services what I'm most interested in is
the economics of very destructive
industries and I thought personally
against the for-profit prison industry
which you unfortunately had some of in
Great Britain and I've also fought
against the the fracking industry oil
gas fracking industry that have been
very successful in both fights and both
of them are driven to this incredible
recklessness by the money that that's
the Dragutin and here in Kansas we've
experienced in my home seven or eight
earthquakes a day because of the way of
fracking ways are injected into the deep
underground in private prisons the
companies have scammed localities to
build really unlike anomic prisons and
and screwed bondholders conned bond
holders in order to evil to build these
things and then to make a profit of
operating them they've got to invent a
reason for literally tens of thousands
of people to be held in prison hey Frank
can you bring this to a conclusion yeah
I mean it's really did everything you
speaking is kind of close to my heart if
Eric Schlosser wasn't about to bring out
a book about the American prison system
I would love to write a book about that
his last book I think was command and
control
yeah yeah that's right yeah it's been 10
years writing something about the
American prison system and which has
always stopped me from doing it because
you active for-profit prisons is an
incredibly interesting topic have you
picked a new topic for your next book no
not yet not yeah I would I think that
the prison system effects lush haven't
got there before me an answer to that
question I do you know I do write about
money I mean in the psychopathy test
I've asked a lot about the
pharmaceutical industry and what I focus
in on is childhood bipolar disorder
because that's that's so baffling and so
unbelievable and yeah and in so you've
been publicly shamed I write about the
money that you know Google and Twitter
make words you know out of shaming
whereas we get nothing and I mean the
word nothing in both senses of the word
Cinthia a few minutes left in our
program with Jon Ronson Colorado Springs
Colorado hi John I've in the interest of
full disclosure I when the movie came
out the men who stare at goats I was on
the board to the International and
reviewing Association and I also agree
with your characteristic of the
difference between the movie in the film
but since we're talking about so many
wonderful topics and you've now given me
two more books I have to go out and get
right away the book and the movie both
picked out the wilder more colorful
aspects to remote viewing and I wanted
to know did you actually get into any of
the actual data because there was so
much value to a lot of the work that
they did and a lot of the work that
they're still doing teaching people how
to do this and I didn't want to leave
people with the impression that the only
part of remote viewing is the funny wild
card or something to be shamed you might
think right um thank you guys for that
question and you know I mean you've used
obviously betterment affair goats
booking and I and I don't I did sit in
on on some remote viewing sessions in
Midwood prudence Calabrese II and Eddie
Danes and I met Tomac monocle and skip
out waters like so I met a lot of the
kind of big remote viewing luminaries in
the end I didn't do much about that and
the main reason why I didn't was because
jim's novel written his book remote
viewers and I didn't want to I didn't
want to kind of tread on his turf
there's so really the men aesthetic go
there's only one chapter about remote
viewing and
most of it's about this other stuff you
know it's about dealing with the tip of
the iceberg
then the men stare guts was really
interested in interested in the iceberg
and in the stuff that hadn't come out at
all add it through that I you know will
to sort of skeptical comics oh my god of
that picture of me after as to that I
like to skeptical comic book about all
of this stuff but I went outside to stay
shaving it was more likely comic that's
the last time we give a guest a monitor
to see what was coming coming next who
is in this picture that we're looking at
this is in so you've been publicly [ __ ]
okay I am a magazine asked me you know
this had two dishes issue
yes me although you might be mistaken to
thinking it was gentle
I think yeah um I was deeply ashamed
basically what happened was I was asked
by a magazine to dress up as a woman you
know this is there's a tradition in
journalism of like black like me about
you know a white man would would stay in
their skin dark and then live you know
in segregated Louisiana in the 1960s and
and then so I remember like after the
after 9/11 somebody said to me would you
stay in your skin and go and live in the
Muslim community follow what you want
you want me to like spy on Muslim so I
can know maybe boots that around a very
persuasive editor said to me okay we've
got one black black black maybe it's
going to be so interesting we want to
like make you a woman and then you can
lie live like a woman and we've got a
prosthetic artist who could like make
you look exactly like a woman and you
can walk like a one-eyed go to the oh
I'll give it a try so the prosthetics
artists like spent ages making me a
prosthetic head and I slipped it on and
I basically look like a woman with a
gigantic head and this okay forget about
the prosthetics we can still make you
looking
he like a woman yeah so here's like a
padded bra
I'm gonna make you walk like a woman and
he's a wag and and there's just me up
and test photographs were taken and I
walked up to the editor I'm in the
office and you're kind of gulped and
anyone ah you look so much like a woman
now go out and experience life as a
woman and I would like I don't think I
look like them
even though you look exactly I'll go you
look just like a woman go go
and so I like seen a good sellers well I
love to do those saying to like really
awesome well I think this fur coats over
and I don't get the circus
that's about looking back about walking
towards the outside world looking
nothing like a woman and my heart is
pounding I suddenly realize oh my god
humiliation factors so largely in the
life of the journalist you know the the
personal avoidance of it and the
professional bostonia dirt onto other
people I can't do this I can't do it and
I stopped and and she was a disappointed
the editor and I just couldn't do it and
I thought nobody must ever see the
photographs and be dressed as a woman so
when I was writing so he'd been publicly
shamed I started to look about my own
fear of shaming and I realized that that
photograph of me as a woman would have
been utterly horrific to me if it got
out so that's why in an attempt to
eradicate it same from their life I
included a photograph in book duvall
posts on our Facebook page I once saw an
obscured documentary made by you called
Stanley Kubrick's boxes I would just
like you to share some of your thoughts
about Stanley Kubrick his films and the
making of that document so so what
happened I mean the very first
documentary I ever made in about 1995
was called Hotel Auschwitz and it was
about the marketing of the concentration
camp it so shortly after it came off I
got a telephone call from this posh
sounding man said my employer would like
a copy of your documentary and I said
who's your employer and he said I'm not
at liberty to tell you and I said
Oh God and it all gets done deconflict
so that's pretty easy and so I sent the
tape and waited and then nothing
happened and then Sally Kubik died and
then a few months after he died this man
phoned again Tony and said Tony through
and he was skubick so I had man's about
30 years he said you want to come up to
the house for lunch and everybody knew
the family Kubrick lifted miss kind of
mysterious house between you know north
of London between since Albans and
heartened them you know it become like
the stuff of legend become that kind of
you know Xanadu like about the first
mansion and there were all these like
rumors and could because alive you know
that it was you know just crazy house so
if I went up to this house in GG's house
that was full of boxes boxes everywhere
it looked like the kind of Internal
Revenue Service had taken over this
house years ago because it was like huge
and opulent but there was no opulence
with all was a utilitarian boxes and
filing cabinets and and so on so I said
what's what's in the boxes and they said
everything so I you know Stanley never
threw anything away so I went back home
and I said to my wife you know boxes
this is you gotta ask them to look for
the boxes so so I think I looked through
the boxes and I said okay so I spent
years you know maybe a couple of times a
month going up there so stood a big
guardian piece and this is extracted in
my collection lost at sea and then it's
a documentary Stanley Kubrick's dog says
well I'll look through every single box
well actually my my favorite thing that
I found in the box and actually there's
a key foes it's one was I saw one on my
first day I saw the stocks it's their
damn sniper head scary so I stood up and
it was the severed head of the snipers
and Full Metal Jacket so I'm kind of
holding a teller of the head at night
but it's higher and the same Christian
Kubrick walked fast this is in that barn
and I said I found the head and she went
is it Ryan O'Neal's head but no it's bad
from the smell
to influence for Metal Jacket and went
but she wasn't the headed she was saw
and I said I know and then I wouldn't
and yeah but then my favorite one was I
found all these photographs in a porter
cabin behind the house that was
photographs of London and South East
England thousands of doorways mortuaries
costume shops and it was all location
research eyes wide shut and they were
almost all taken by Kubrick's nephew
Manuel so I went to see Manuel to hear
about him going off to do this he said
he was doing up like a year took thirty
thousand photographs over like a year I
said wasn't a good year it was a great
year
he said you know good the best moment
this was my favorite moment for my whole
Kubrick adventure was he said Google
wanted him to take photographs of the
whole of this really long street in
London cook for long straight he said
but he didn't want the buildings tilting
back or forward we had to take a ladder
so every day he'd go to commercial I
take a lot of cloud the ladder take a
photograph come down loofa ladder and
tilt like the weeks and weeks and weeks
a Kubrick's loading up coding in any
there you nearly there nearly must be
Delhi finished and then finally he like
gets to the under commercial road goes
to snappy snaps gets the photos
developed seller tapes them all together
you've got this like perfect panorama of
the whole of commercial road takes it
back to Kubrick's house let alone
corridor Kubrick comes out of his room
looks at it and goes well it sure beats
going there you can just have gotten it
that'll be the last word with author Jon
Ronson on in depth thank you thank you